CALLED IMMEDIATELY- BECAUSE WE
CAN START WITHOUT A QUORUM BUT
LET ME FIRST SAY THAT IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY WE ARE LIMITING AS WE
HAVE BEEN NONESSENTIAL GATHERING
SENATE. HEARING TO OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING A FACE COVERING.
PRIDE LINES AND WE MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN ORDER
TO ASSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING. IN THE
CAPITOL SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THE REMOTE MEMBERS
TODAY OUR SENATORS TORONTO MEN
AND STERN. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THEY WILL ALSO BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS REMEMBER THAT YOU
MUTE YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING THE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED YOU
SHOULD RAISE THEIR HAND FEATURE-
AND THEN. WHEN I RECOGNIZE YOU
THE POP UP WINDOW WILL ASK TO
UNMUTE YOU SELECT ON YOU BEFORE
YOU BEGIN- R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU'RE FINISHED TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN THIS
HEARING ROOM. AND WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. IF
YOU WANT TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND YOU ARE DOING IT TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
844-291-4185 YOU WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED. ON THE SCREEN. AND
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
IT WORKS REFERRED TO THE SENATE
OR THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME THEN WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN THE QUEUE
AND THE MODERATOR WILL CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AND YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY. AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR. HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. I'M NOW. TO
BEGIN THIS IS OUR FIRST BUDGET
HEARING OF THE YEAR AND IT IS TO
PROVIDE US AN OVERVIEW OF THE
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR
PRESENTED ON JANUARY THE TENTH-
ONE THIS INITIAL MEETING WILL OF
COURSE BE FOLLOWED BY NUMEROUS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SO FAR FIVE
SEVEN COMMITTEES. WHICH IN
ADDITION TO FULL COMMITTEEHEARINGS ON THE PROJECT- AND OF
COURSE MORE IN DEPTH DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL SKIN THAT
JANUARY TEN BUDGET WILL TAKE
PLACE IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEES.
SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS WILL BEGIN
EARLIER THAN NORMAL WE EXPECT TO
HAVE HEARINGS THROUGHOUT THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY AND INTO THE
FIRST WEEK OF MARCH- THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR
REFLECTS A CONTINUATION OF
STRONG ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR OUR
STATE AND VERY STRONG REVENUES-
WE I THINK ALL OF US WHO ARE
PART OF THIS PROCESS KNOW. THAT
SINCE THE RECESSION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN AN NUMBER
OF MEASURES TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S FISCAL RESILIENCY. AND
AS A RESULT. WE HAVE WE ARE IN
THIS SITUATION WITH VERY HEALTHY
REVENUES. HOWEVER THE FISCAL
RECOVERY THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
SPENT ON EQUAL THERE IS A RECENT
OXFAM REPORT THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THIS. THE WEALTH OF THE WORLD'S
TEN RICHEST MEN. DOUBLED FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION TWO ONE
POINT FIVE TRILLION JUST IN THE
TWO YEARS OF THIS PANDEMIC. WELL
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION NOT ONLY IN OUR STATE
BUT ELSEWHERE. HAVE LOST INCOME
DURING COVERT NINETEEN. SO THE
FOCUS OF OUR BUDGET SHOULD NOT
ONLY BE ON PROVIDING THE MUCH
NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO SUSTAIN ALL
OF US TO THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
ON BUILDING A FUTURE THAT IS
MORE EQUITABLE FOR CALIFORNIA.
OUR SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
RELEASED HE VALUES IN DECEMBER.
AND OUR OUR HEADLINE FOR THAT
WAS TO PUT CALIFORNIA'S WEALTH
TO WORK FOR A MORE EQUITABLE
ECONOMY. AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS OUTLINED IN JANUARY
TENTH COMPLIMENT MANY OF THE
SENATE'S PRIORITIES AND
RECOMMEND THE DEPLOYMENT OF
RESOURCES WITH THE GOAL OF
IMPROVING THE FUTURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. NOW WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE ARE STILL IN THE MIDST
OF THIS COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND IT CONTINUES TO
IMPACT ALL FACETS OF OUR LIVES
INCLUDING OUR SCHOOLS OUR
BUSINESSES AND SO MUCH MORE. IN
ADDITION WE FACE THAT WE
CALIFORNIA FACE NUMEROUS OTHER
CHALLENGES INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS. OR LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR SHORTAGE
OF HOUSING IN GENERAL HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD. OUR HOUSING THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE URGENT
CLIMATE CRISIS ISSUES. SUCH AS
WILD FIRES AND DROUGHT. AND THEN
AS WE'VE SEEN WELL IT IS BEEN
PRESENT. WE'VE SEEN IT
EXACERBATED DURING THE PANDEMIC
B. MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES OF MANY
PEOPLE. WHETHER DUE TO THE
ISOLATION OR OTHER REASONS AND
THE NEED TO RESPOND WITH
ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
. AND ALSO WHEN WE'RE IN A TIME
LIKE THIS WHERE WE HAVE SOME-
HIGHER THAN PROJECTED REVENUES
AND ALSO FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN LOOK TO.
OUR EDUCATION FACILITIES AND
OTHERS THAT MAY NEED SUPPORT TO
STRENGTHEN THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OF COURSE WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING IN THIS AT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE WORK FOR SHORTAGES IN
THE STATE SOME OF THEM. FOR A
FOR REASONS FOR PEOPLE NOT
WILLING YET TO GO BACK TO WORK
OR NOT ABLE TO BECAUSE OF LACK
OF CHILD CARE OR OTHER SERVICES
AND SOME OF THEM BECAUSE WE'VE
HAD A SHORTAGE FOR YEARS WHETHER
IT'S A NURSING TEACHING MENTAL
HEALTH OR OTHER SOME OTHER.
WORKFORCE CATEGORIES WHICH WE
SHOULD LOOK AT HOW TO STRENGTHEN
SO THE WORK WE ARE DOING IS
ESSENTIAL AS IT HAS EVER BEEN I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
AS A COMMITTEE TO COMPLETE THE
SENATE'S WORK IN CRAFTING THE
STATE'S BUDGET. AND PUTTING
FORWARD OUR- OUR OWN-
PERSPECTIVES ON WHAT WAS PRETTY
MUCH WHAT AND PERHAPS NEW
INITIATIVES. SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND I WELCOME
ALL OF YOU TO COMMITTEE TODAY
LET'S SEE IF WERE- MISTER SECOND
SHARK MINI CONSOLE IN DO YOU
THINK DO WE HAVE A SHOULD WE DO
ROLL CALL. WE HAVE A FORM YET.
NO SO WHAT WE MAY WE MAY
CONTINUE AS A COMMITTEE A
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE WILL DO THAT
AGAIN THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WE WON'T BE TAKING
ACTION. SO WE CAN CONTINUE SO.
BEFORE I GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SENATOR NELSON
AS THE VICE CHAIR YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE. NO
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FROM. ERICA
LEE WHO IS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- DIRECTOR LEE ARE YOU
READY. THAT'S GOOD MORNING
EXCELLENT I'LL BE HAPPY NEW YEAR
GREAT I'M IN YOUR QUEUE YEAH.
THE MORNING SURE SCANNER BY
STERNHELL SAID EFFORTS OF THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HERE AND I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO THE
COMMITTEE THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE GOVERNORS BUDGET.
THIS BUDGET BUILDS ON LAST
YEAR'S EXTRAORDINARY BUDGET AND
INVESTMENTS THAT PROTECTED LIVES
DURING THE COPA NINETY DAMAGE
WILL ALSO PROVIDING. SUPPORT TO
FAMILIES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
AND ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE AND
LONG TERM IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE SOME NOTABLE INVESTMENTS
FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDE
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS. EXPANDING ACCESS TO
MEDICARE FOR OLDER ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
. BASEMENTS AND HEALTHY THINGS
ACCOUNTS STUDENT HOUSING AND
EXPANSION OF FINANCIAL AID. TO
LOWER THE COST OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR FAMILIES AND OF
COURSE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
DRESS WILDFIRES DROUGHTS AND
EXTREME WEATHER. THE STATE IS
CONTINUING TO EXPERIENCE RECORD
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND THAT ON TOP
OF A DECADE THIS CALL PRINCE
REALLY GIVES US MORE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD ON OUR PAST INVESTMENTS
AND STRENGTHEN THE FOUNDATION.
OF OUR FUTURE HOWEVER AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED IN HER
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS NOT ALL
CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC COVERED
EQUALLY AT STILL FACE CHALLENGES
THIS BUDGET RECOGNIZES THIS AND
ATTEMPTS TO SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE GOVERNORS BUDGET
TAKES ON SOME OF THE STATE'S
BIGGEST CHALLENGES NAMELY CPA
NINETEEN. CLIMATE CHANGE
HOMELESSNESS. COST OF LIVING
KEEPING OUR STREETS SAFE. BUT IT
ALSO CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES TO BUILD A VIBRANT
AND MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY. SO
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
BENEFIT. THE BETTER PRESENTATION
NOT SURPRISED WITH KOBE NINETEEN
THE STATE CONTINUES ITS SCIENCE
BASED APPROACH TO FIGHT COVER
NINETEEN SUPPORTING MORE
TESTING. AND VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION THAT LOT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET INCLUDED ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION FOR
DIRECT RESPONSE EFFORTS. SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF THE BUDGET
HOWEVER WE'VE DEALT WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES AROUND
THE DELTA VARIANT OUT OVER
CRIMES. INCLUDING SUPPORTING
HOSPITAL AND MEDICAL SEARCH
EFFORTS ADDITIONALLY MORE
CHILDREN ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR
THE VACCINE THE STATE HAS REALLY
RAMPED UP EFFORTS TO GET MORE
BACK MORE CHILDREN VACCINATED TO
REDUCE. THE RISK OF SPRITE. WE
ARE REQUESTING EARLY ACTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
FISCAL YEAR TO CONTINUE THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE.
BUT IT ALSO REFLECTS ANOTHER ONE
POINT THREE BILLION FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR TO CONTINUE COPING
NINETEEN AFTER. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE GOVERNORS
BUDGET ALL DOGS TO GET
COMMITMENTS MADE IN PRIOR. TO
FURTHER SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
PARENTS WITH YOUNG CHILDREN AND
TO REDUCE THE OVERALL COST OF
LIVING. IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH A
PARENT'S AGENDA. MANY PARENTS
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
THE COOK NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HEALTHCARE CENTERS CLOSED
SCHOOLS TRANSITION TO DISTANCE
LEARNING SOME PARENTS HAD TO
DROP OUT OF THE WORKFORCE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN. THE
BUDGET ADDS THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS AND THIS IS
ON TOP OF A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS AT IT LAST YEAR. THE GOAL
IS TO GET TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND IT'S LOTS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. THE
BUDGET ALL COMPLETE ONE BILLION
TO INVEST IN FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN-
INCREASING ACCESS FOR FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND. CHILDREN AND REDUCING
THE ADULT. RATIO AND T. K.
CLASSROOMS. PASSERSBY MADE A ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOWN PAYMENT
TO EXPAND AFTER SCHOOL AND
SUMMER SCHOOL PROGRAMS. THIS
BUDGET CONTINUES NOT AN ADS
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION I'M
GOING- FOR EXTENDED DAY AND YOUR
LONG DESTRUCTION AS WELL AS
ENCOURAGEMENT FOR ALL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TUDENTS. AFTER THAT AT
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
BILLION FOR INTEGRATING ARTS AND
MUSIC. ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS. BUT
IT ALSO EXPANDS THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT WHICH PROVIDES A
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT TO FAMILIES. WITH
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
I. H. FIVE YEARS UNDER. THIS IS
EXPANDED TO FAMILIES THAT I'LL
RETURN NO INCOME AS WELL AS- A
PROPOSAL TO INDEX THE CREDIT TO
INFLATION SO TO PREVENT THE
ORIGINAL TAX CREDITS VALUE. IN
HIGHER EDUCATION THE BUDGET
PROPOSES MULTI YEAR CONTRACTS
WITH THE UC AND CSU AT A MULTI
YEAR ROADMAP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THE STATE
WILL PROVIDE 5% BASED
APPLICATIONS FOR THE DURATION OF
THIS COMPACT. AND ROADMAP- AS
WELL AS- EXPECTATION THAT
SEGMENTS ARE EXPECTED TO EXPAND
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
I JUST AFFORDABILITY ISSUES-
NAMELY VERY TIMELY DEGREE
COMPLETION THAT CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET FOR
THEIR SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO REDUCE
THE OVERALL COST OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THREE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- FOR STUDENT
HOUSING THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR
THREE YEARS OR TWO BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN STUDENT
HOUSING. AND AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND CAL
GRANTS. TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AS A RESULT OF CHANGES
BE MADE TO THE CAL GRANT-
PROGRAM LAST YEAR SHE- FOR THE
FIRST YEAR UP A REVAMPED MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. THAT WILL
REDUCE THE TOTAL COST OF. THOSE
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES. CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND TO TACKLE
CLIMATE CHANGE IN TIME. THE
FIRST THE BUDGET RESTORES THE
BUSINESS TAX CREDITS INCLUDING
OUR RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT WHICH
WERE LIMITED DURING THE-
RECESSION AND PROPOSES TWO NEW
GREEN TAX CREDITS THE FIRST IS
THAT YOU WANT TO FIFTY MILLION
PER YEAR CREDIT FOR THREE YEARS.
A QUALIFIED COMPANIES THAT ARE
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA AND
ARE INVESTING IN RESEARCH TO
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
SECOND ONE IS A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR TAX CREDIT PER
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS- TO DEVELOP
CLEAN ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES AND
THIS IS STRUCTURE THIS IS. A NEW
KIND OF A NEW TYPE OF TAX CREDIT
BUT IT'S STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT WOULD BUSINESSES BECOME
PROFITABLE A SHARE OF THEIR
PROFITS WILL BE RETURNED TO THE
STATE OF. CALIFORNIA TO BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS. ADDITIONALLY
DISTRICTS IN. RESERVES OF
LITHIUM- AND LITHIUM IS ABOUT
ALL THAT VITAL FOR BATTERIES AND
ELECTRIC CARS AS WELL AS
COMPUTER ELECTRONICS. THE SIX
POINTS TO BECOME A GLOBAL LEADER
IN BUYING ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
TECHNOLOGY TO PRODUCE THE FRUIT.
TO PRODUCE LITHIUM AND BECOME A
WORLD CLASS BATTERY
MANUFACTURER. WE PROPOSE WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AT STAKE
HOLDERS TO DEVELOP OUR
REGULATORY PROCESS- RESEARCH
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK AROUND
LOOKING PRODUCTION THAT WILL
PROVIDE GOOD JOBS AND EXPAND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IN THE
SALTON SEA REGION. IN CALIFORNIA
MORE BROADLY. IT ALSO DIRECTED
INC RELATED RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AT THE U. C. TO
SUPPORT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
INNOVATIONS ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN ADDITION THE BUDGET
IMPASSE OVER TWENTY BILLION IN
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED
INVESTMENTS. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
THESE INVESTMENTS FOR MORE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. SUPPORTING
OUR CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL LIKEWISE STRIVE FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND JOB CREATION
OPERATE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
SUPPORTED THE NATION'SLARGEST
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS FEW REVERSE
LOANS AND GRANTS AND PROVIDED
BILLIONS IN NEEDED RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESS. THE BUDGET BUILD
ON THOSE INVESTMENTS THE
PROPOSED STATE TAX CONFORMITY
FOR QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS AND VENUES THAT
RECEIVED A FEDERAL POLICE
FRIENDS. OF THE BUDGET PROPOSES
THE WAIVING OF FILING FEES FOR
NEW BUSINESSES IT ALSO PROPOSES
EXPANDING PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO FOR
BUSINESS CREATION IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN WAIT
LISTED FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROGRAM I JUST MENTIONED.
AND FINALLY THREE BILLION OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS TO REDUCE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND OVER
THE LONG TERM THIS WILL REDUCE
COSTS BUT IT'S D. AS WELL AS
BENEFIT EMPLOYERS REDUCING THAT. HUMILIATED DURING THE PAST
THAT MAKES. WELL OUR SMALL
BUSINESS IS VITAL STATE
CONTINUED GROWTH SO MUST IN
FAST. IN OUR DIVERSE WORKFORCE.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES STRATEGIES
TRAIN WORKERS FOR JOBS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO OUR ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND YOU NEED TO MASTER TEACHERS
AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS. WE ARE
SEEING SHORTAGES ON THE BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
TO DEVELOP COLLAGEN FOR PATHWAYS
THIS IS THROUGH THE K. TWELVE.
SYSTEM FOCUSED YEAH. THE FUTURE
ANOTHER ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
FOR THE KARRAKATTA ME TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF NURSES
SOCIAL WORKERS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS BEHAVIOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AMONG OTHER
POSITIONS AND BUILDING UPON LAST
YEAR'S TWO POINT NINE BILLION AT
ASPEN FOR TEACHERS THE BUDGET WE
CAN START YOUR CREDENTIAL ABUSE
AS WELL EXAMINATION AND
ENCOURAGES NEW INTEGRATED
TEACHER PREP PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S. TEACHER SHORTAGE.
BUDGET INCLUDES MULTIPLE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS WITH A
FOCUS ON CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDING A ONE HUNDRED TEN
MILLION OR EIGHT SIX MOVEMENT.
TRAINING CENTER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND TWO TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION TO SUPPORT
OIL AND GAS WELL OIL AND GAS
WELL CAPPING EFFORTS TRAINING
AND FRANCE TO DISPLACE WORKERS
AT THE STATE FACES OUT OF OIL
PRODUCTION. AFTER THE BUDGET
INTO THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION OR
AT THE COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE UNDER SEARCH. FOR
REGIONAL STRATEGIES THAT
DIVERSIFY LOCAL ECONOMIES AND
NEEDS MORE SUSTAINABLE
INDUSTRIES THIS BUDGET
COMPLIMENTS THAT PART WITH FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS THEIR
ECONOMIES. TO MOVING AWAY FROM
OIL AND GAS. AND IMPORTANTLY THE
MINISTRATION WANTS TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO CRAFT A NEW
PAID SICK LEAVE PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA WORKERS NOW
AS WE DEAL WITH THE REALITIES OF
WORKING DURING A PANDEMIC WE ARE
PROPOSING EARLY ACTION ON PAID
SICK LEAVE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS TOPIC AS
WELL AS ON THE COMPUTER AT COST.
AND LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC FIFTEEN
MILLION CLIMATE INVESTMENT THE
BUDGET INTEGRATES CLIMATE EQUITY
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. WITH
OUR INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING HEALTH
AND EDUCATION. IT'S TOTALED OVER
TWENTY MILLION AND ALIGNED
EFFORTS TO RESPOND TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND MOVE FORWARD
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. FOR
WILDFIRES ADDING TO OUR LAST
YEAR'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT THE BUDGET
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
TWO BILLION FOR FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION EFFORTS. AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT ARE
DEDICATED FOR DEDICATED AIRCRAFT
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT. AND CRUISE
AND FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
SATISFIED TO DRESS WORKLOAD AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES FOR CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS. BUILDING UPON
LAST YEAR'S FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT
DRUG RESPONSE AND LONG TERM
WATER SUSTAINABILITY THE
BUDGETING THE OTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ON TOP OF
THE ONE BILLION ALREADY PLANNED%
FOR IMMEDIATE NEEDS SUCH AS
PARTICLE DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCIES- FOR SMALL FARMERS
AND RANCHERS AT SUPPORT FOR
WATER SYSTEM IS FACING A LOT OF.
WATER SUPPLY. IT'S REALLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK TO INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA AN
INVESTOR CAN EXPECT TO RECEIVE
BILLIONS IN TRANSPORTATION FROM
THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS AFTER I G.
H. OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
THESE FUNDS. WILL HELP OUT SINCE
JOBS IN ADDITION THE BUDGET
INCLUDES NINE POINT ONE BILLION
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THAT WILL
SUPPORT THE CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NATION'S
FIRST. I AM. VERY PROUD MY
APOLOGIES FOR INTERRUPTING. I'VE
JUST LEARNED THAT WE'RE HAVING A
PROBLEM HERE WITH OUR AUDIO. AND
WHILE WE CAN HEAR YOU HEAR IN
THE CHAMBERS ANYONE ARE REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT BEING ABLE
TO HEAR YOU AND- R. WHAT WE'RE
CASTING IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
HEAR YOU SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO JUST DO A BRIEF RECESS. SO WE
CAN FIX THAT AUDIO PROBLEM AND
THEY WILL RETURN TO YOU OKAY. SO
WHAT IS EVERYONE BRIEF RECESS
WHILE WE DEAL WITH OUR
TECHNOLOGY PROBLEM THANK YOU.
IT WAS ONLY A
PROBLEM VIA OUR EIGHTEEN T. LINE
OUR RECORDING OF THE HEARING
THROUGH COMCAST AND ANYONE
WATCHING THROUGH THAT ROUTE WAS
ABLE TO SH TO HEAR AND SEE THE
FULL PRESENTATION AND WE HAVE
RECORDED AND HAVE THE FULL
PRESENTATION WE ALSO HAVE OUR
OWN REMOTE MEMBERS COULD HERE SO
WE DO NOT NEED TO START OVER WE
CAN JUST RESUME WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
MAKE THEIR PRESENTATION AND THEN
I WILL IMMEDIATELY TURN TO THE
LA- ALLOW THE LA- TO MAKE THEIR
PRESENTATION THEN I WILL TURN TO
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS AND THEN I
WILL TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
PUBLIC WE DO HAVE A HARD STOP AT
NOON SO I JUST WANT TO LET.
EVERYONE KNOW THAT- AND LET'S
TURN BACK TO OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND DEPUTY SECRETARY LEE
PRIEST PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- OKAY SO I BELIEVE I
WAS ON TRANSPORTATION SO I WILL
TAKE UP- RESUME THERE. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES NINE POINT ONE
BILLION IN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING THAT WILL SUPPORT
CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF THE
NATION'S FIRST ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM. AND REGIONAL
TRANSIT RAIL PROJECTS ALONG WITH
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN PROJECTS
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROJECTS
ON TOP OF THOSE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THE BUDGET ALSO ADDS
AN ADDITIONAL SIX POINT ONE
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR A
ZERO EMISSION PACKAGE. THIS IS
ADDED TO LAST YEAR'S THREE POINT
NINE BILLION BRINGING THE TOTAL
INVESTMENT TEN BILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS TO ADVANCE OUR CLIMATE AND
OUR TRANSPORTATION GOALS AGAIN
TO. REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. ON THE BUDGET MAKES
INVESTMENTS TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS WITH TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR LONG
DURATION STORAGE PROJECTS
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION AND
DECARBONISATION OF EXISTING
BUILDINGS. IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. OUR HOUSE IN THE
BUDGET INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION OVER TWO
YEARS TO ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN AND NEAR DOWNTOWN-
THIS IS BUILDING ON HOUSING-
SORRY THIS BUILDING THIS MEANS
BUILDING HOUSING. JOBS SCHOOLS
AND SERVICES TO REDUCE COMMUTES
OUT THERE FOR IN HOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WELL. AND THE BUDGET
INCLUDES ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND LOW INCOME TAX
CREDIT. IN THE AREA OF
HEALTHCARE CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY ADVANCED MULTIPLE
MEASURES IN RECENT YEARS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THROUGH THIS
BUDGET CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE
FIRST STATE TO REALIZE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO HEALTH COVERAGE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. LOSING THE
REMAINING GAP AND COVERING
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGE
TWENTY NINE. TWENTY FOUR TO
FORTY NINE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. BUT IT ALSO
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPROVING HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AND PROPOSES
THIRTY MILLION TO CREATE. THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. IN LATE DECEMBER
IS THE MASK FEDERAL CMS APPROVED
R. KELLY PUZZLE ALLOWING
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
MEDIC HEALTH REFORMS INCLUDING
FUNDS TO SUPPORT ENHANCED CARE
MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS. AS WELL AS FUNDS TO
BUILD STATE WHAT CAPACITY FOR
JUSTICE INVOLVED PERSONS TO
RECEIVE PRE AND POST RELEASE
SERVICES. BUT IT ALSO ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE SERVICES
IMPROVING CLINICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
EXPANDING THE WORKFORCE IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. CONTINUING
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
HOMELESSNESS THE STATE HAS
INVESTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
CRITICAL HOUSING SUPPORTS AND
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES NOTABLE IS
LAST YEAR'S TWELVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION. INCLUDING
BILLIONS FOR CONTINUING CARE AND
SENIOR INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
INVESTMENT. THE BUDGET PROPOSES
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION OVER TWO YEARS TO
PROVIDE BRIDGE HOUSING AND
SERVICES UNTIL THOSE INVESTMENTS
FROM PRIOR YEARS CAN COME ONLINE
. AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IS INCLUDED FOR IN
CATHOLIC FRANCE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING THE FIFTY MILLION
INCLUDED AT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
LASTLY THE BUDGET SUPPORTS
KEEPING CALIFORNIA STREET STATE
AND INVEST TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION TO BOLSTER LOCAL
LIFE FORCE MEANT RESPONSE TO
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT CRIME AND
TO SUPPORT LOCAL PROSECUTORS AND
HOLDING PERPETRATORS.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE CRIMES.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE BILLION FOR LOCAL
GOT BUYBACK PROGRAMS AND TWENTY
MILLION TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED. BY RETAIL THEFT-
INCLUSION THIS IS A BRIEF
SYNOPSIS OF SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT AND EXCITING
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ACT SAID THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAS ALWAYS SERVED AS A
LAUNCHING PAD FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE WITH LEGISLATURE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE CONVERSATION
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING STARTING
WITH THOSE ISSUES WHICH WE ASK
FOR EARLY ACTION UPCOMING
NINETEEN DIRECT COSTS AND PAID
SICK LEAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I AM JOINED BY SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES AND WHEN THE TIME IS
HERE WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
MEMBER QUESTIONS- AFTER THE LA-
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU SECRETARIAL DEPARTMENT'S
DEPUTY SECRETARY LEE- APOLOGIES
THAT WE HAD TO HAVE THAT
INTERRUPTION BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OVERVIEW YOU'VE
PROVIDED I'M SURE THERE WILL BE
MEMBER QUESTIONS BUT LET ME TURN
NOW TO OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
MR PADDOCK. GO AHEAD. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND- MR BACK CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WERE INVITING US TO BE HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AT THIS
HEARING. MY NAME IS DAVE
HEADACHES- LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
AND- I TODAY TO HAND OUT THAT I
AM QUICKLY SHARING ON THE
SCREEN- AND THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU IS ALSO AVAILABLE ALONG WITH
OUR YOUTH AND- REVIEW GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PORT. ON OUR WEBSITE AT
ILIO DOT CA DOT GOV. FOR ANYBODY
FOLLOWING FROM THE OUTSIDE- AND
THEN- IT AFTER I GIVE MY REMARKS
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE OFFICE
WILL BE HAPPY ALSO TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS- THAT NUMBERS MAY
HAVE- BUT- BEFORE. I GO INTO THE
HAND OUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
NOTE THAT- YOU'LL HEAR ME
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S ESTIMATED
SURPLUS. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
RESPONSE TO THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS WENT AHEAD- THE-
COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAJOR PROPOSALS AND
THEN SOME- CLOSING REMARKS ON.
OUR VIEW OF THE STATE'S BUDGET
CONDITION AND RESERVES AND SO
THROUGHOUT THESE COMMENTS I
THINK THAT YOU'LL BE F. TEAM
MEMBERS- IN WHICH WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO KEEP IN MIND. HOW TO
PRESERVE LEGISLATIVE
FLEXIBILITY. AND TO ALSO KEEP IN
MIND WAYS TO- YOU KNOW ON THE
MARGIN CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN
THE STATE'S FISCAL RESILIENCE.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
ONGOING UNCERTAINTY RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC. RISING INFLATION.
AND ANY NUMBER OF OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AND I JUST WOULD YOU KNOW WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT RESERVED AND
RESILIENCE I I'D LIKE TO JUST
UNDERSCORED THAT WE ARE NOT
SAYING THAT JUST FOR THEIR OWN
SAKE- OR EVEN SOME ABSTRACT
NOTION OF FISCAL PRUDENCE. IT'S
REALLY SO THAT THE STATE CAN BE
IN A STRONG POSITION TO UPHOLD
THE COMMITMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PREVIOUSLY MADE.
AND SO THAT THE STATE CAN
SUSTAIN VITAL PROGRAMS. FOR IT
FOR OUR RESIDENTS IN THE EVENT
OF ANOTHER UNEXPECTED. SHOCK OR
A DOWNTURN. SO WITH THAT- I
WILL- GO AHEAD AND GO INTO THE-
TO THE HAND OUT HERE BEGINNING
ON PAGE ONE- HERE WE HAVE TO
FIGURE IS THE FIRST ONE ON THE
TOP DISPLAYED THE WAY THAT. THE
GOVERNOR- ALLOCATE THE
DISCRETIONARY SURPLUS ON THE NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF
THE BUDGET AS YOU KNOW WE RUN
OUR OWN INDEPENDENT CALCULATIONS
OF HAT THE SURPLUS IS AND IN
THIS YEAR'S EXERCISE WE CAME TO
A CONCLUSION THAT THERE WAS A
SURPLUS OF ABOUT. TWENTY NINE
BILLION WHICH IS A BIT LARGER
THAN- WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IDENTIFIED IN THE IN THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOCUMENT OF.
TWENTY ONE BILLION. I WOULD KNOW
WHAT IT WAS THE TWENTY NINE
BILLION IS. FAIRLY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE HAD ESTIMATED BACK IN
OUR NOVEMBER OUTLOOK JUST TO
KIND OF KEEP. THE NUMBERS IT- IT
FAMILIAR TO YOU- WE HAD
ESTIMATED A THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLAR. DISCRETIONARY SURPLUS
NOW WE HAVE TO MEET THE GOVERNOR
CAME TO ABOUT TWENTY NINE
BILLION ALTHOUGH THEY IDENTIFIED
TWENTY ONE BILLION. SO THE-
BASICALLY WE HAVE I THINK I
BELIEVE OUR OFFICES APPROACH THE
ESTIMATION OF THE DISCRETIONARY
SURPLUS VERY. SIMILAR WAY USING
A SIMILAR METHODOLOGY. BUT WHERE
WE DIFFER. IN THIS CASE IS THAT-
ART YEAH THE ADMINISTRATION
TREATS SOME. SPENDING AGREEMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BUT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ENACTED IN LIFE. AS
PART OF THE STATE SPENDING BASE
. WHERE IS WE TREAT THEM AS
STILL DISCRETIONARY CHOICES OF
THE LEGISLATURE ONE OF THE YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MAIN EXAMPLES
WOULD BE THE THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION- PROPOSED TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH IS
VERY REASONABLE IN OUR VIEW I
MEAN IT REFLECTS THE- SOME
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE MADE LAST
YEAR BUT ULTIMATELY THOSE WERE
NOT ENACTED INTO- BUDGET LAW.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE DID REVIEW
THAT IT'S STILL BEING ADDED A
MATTER OF DISCRETION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SO IT'S REALLY NOT
JUST IN A DIFFERENT HOUSE IN THE
COUNTY IT REALLY REFLECTS A
CONSCIOUS CHOICE ON OUR PART TO.
DEFER TO YOUR AUTHORITY OVER
APPROPRIATIONS AND SO. GIVE ME.
I AM SO WELL YOU MAY GO IT
DECIDED TO ADHERE TO THOSE
AGREEMENTS AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
REFLECTED IN HIS PROPOSAL-
BEFORE THE MONEY CAN BE SPENT IT
WOULD STILL REQUIRE YOU MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION AND SO WE
DON'T. ASSUME THAT UP FRONT- SO
WHEN YOU DO THAT THE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT COMES UP TO TWENTY NINE
BILLION IN A SURPLUS. WHERE IS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAD TWENTY
ONE BILLION. WHEN I TURN TO THAT
FIGURE ON PAGE ONE HERE ARE THE
TOP ONE IS SHOWING HOW THE
GOVERNOR WOULD ALLOCATE THAT
SURPLUS. AND YOU CAN SEE HERE
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
LARGEST AMOUNT IN- ONE TIMER
TEMPORARY PROGRAMMATIC SPENDING
WE CONSIDERED TEMPORARY TO BE
THREE YEARS OR LESS. ABOUT
SEVENTEEN POINT THREE BILLION.
HE HAS. PROPOSED SIX POINT TWO
BILLION OR REVENUE REDUCTION.
AND THEN- HE'S PROPOSING THREE
POINT ONE BILLION TO GO INTO THE
STATE'S DISCRETIONARY RESERVE
WHICH IS THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY. THERE ARE
TWO BILLION IN ONGOING SPENDING
PROPOSALS WHICH WE ESTIMATE
WOULD INCREASE TO ABOUT YOU KNOW
TO MORE THAN FIVE BILLION
THROUGH THE FORECAST TO RISE IN
WHICH IS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. AND THEN THERE'S
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION
IN. DEBT REPAYMENT ON TOP OF THE
FOUR BILLION IN DEBT REPAYMENT
IS REQUIRED BY PROPOSITION TWO.
I WILL ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE BILLION IN WHAT WE CALL
GENERAL PURPOSE RESERVES. THAT
IS THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT THE SAFETY NET RESERVE.
AND THE S. F. B. U. R. SO THOSE
ARE THE ONES WE COUNT WHEN WE
REFER TO TWENTY FIVE BILLION.
THE SECOND FIGURE BUT- HOW TO
START THE SECOND FIGURE ON ON
THE PAGE IS- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SPENDING AND IN THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR PROP NINETY EIGHT N. HERE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF HIGHER
REVENUES WHICH RESULT IN A
HIGHER MINIMUM GUARANTEE THERE'S
ALMOST EIGHTEEN BILLION IN-
PROPOSED NEW SPENDING. AND SO
EVEN AFTER COVERING A FIVE POINT
3% COLA WHICH ISN'T ABOUT A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR COST THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES ALLOCATING ABOUT
THIRTEEN BILLION IN RESOURCES
THEY SHOWN IN THAT IN THAT
FIGURE SEVEN BILLION FOR ONE
TIME ACTIVITY THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION FOR THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
WHICH WAS INITIATED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. ONE POINT TWO BILLION IN
AN ADJUSTMENT FOR DISTRICT-
BECAUSE OF THE STATEWIDE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT SITUATION
BECAUSE THERE IS A JUDGMENT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES THAT- COSTS
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION. AND
THEN- ONE POINT THREE BILLION
AND IN OTHER WORDS SEVERAL
ONGOING INCREASES. AND THEN LIKE
I REFERRED WITH THE BOOK YEAH
DISCRETIONARY GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVES- THERE IS UNDER THE
RULES OF PROPOSITION TWO THIRDS
NOW- THE PROPOSAL REFLECTS THAT
THERE IS NOW GOING TO BE A- PROP
NINETY EIGHT RESERVE. ALMOST TEN
BILLION WHICH IS THE HIGHEST
IT'S BEEN- TODAY SO. THAT IS
NOTABLE. MOVING TO PAGE TWO I
WANTED TO GIVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO THE STATE
APPROPRIATION PLAN ENTERED AGAIN
LIMITED SOMETIMES REFERRED TO
YOU. AND IT- YOU KNOW THE DEATH
AT A HIGH LEVEL. AFFECTS HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN USE REVENUES
THAT EXCEED A CERTAIN THRESHOLD
. AND WHETHER THIS STATE HAS
REQUIREMENTS STEMMING FROM.
EXCEEDING THE FELL FOR THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN IT IS A TWO
YEAR CALCULATION AND SO FOR THE
PRIOR YEAR IN THE CURRENT YEAR
SO TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGES THE GOVERNOR REFLECTS
THE STATE HAS THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS ARE OVER THAT
LIMIT BY A COMBINED TWO POINT
SIX BILLION. THE REQUIREMENT.
WOULD BE MORE THAN THIS WE WOULD
BE OVER THE LIMIT BY MORE THAN
THIS EXCEPT THAT THE BUDGET.
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ABOUT SIX
POINT THREE BILLION AND
PROPOSALS THAT- MEETS OUR
REQUIREMENTS THUS LOWERING.
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THE LIMIT BY THAT AMOUNT- NO
NOTABLY THE GOVERNOR DID NOT
INCLUDE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL FOR
DEALING WITH THESE EXCESS
REVENUES. AND INDICATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL COME BACK
AND PUT FORWARD A PLAN AT THE
MAY REVISION WE HAVE BETTER AND
MORE UP TO DATE INFORMATION.
THAT'S ONE APPROACH BUT WE
ACTUALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN THINKING
ABOUT DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR
MEETING THE FELL REQUIREMENT
BEFORE ME. THE REASON FOR THIS
IS THAT DELAYING THE FORMATION
OF A PLAN. REALLY REDUCES
LEGISLATIVE FLEXIBILITY SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE REVENUES YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN SEEING STRONG REVENUE
TRENDS AS THE CHAIR NOTED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE OF THE HEARING
WE'VE BEEN SEEING VERY STRONG
REVENUE TRENDS AND IF THAT
CONTINUES AND THEY CONTINUE TO
OUTPACE. OUR BUDGET ESTIMATES.
AND THE LEGISLATURE PREFERRED TO
ADDRESS A PORTION OF IT- SAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE PRODUCED
BY THAT- THROUGH LOWERING TAX
REVENUES THEN EARLY ACTION WOULD
BE BETTER THAN WAITING UNTIL MAY
MAY NOT EVEN REALLY BE FEASIBLE
IF YOU WAIT UNTIL THAT POINT IN
THE FISCAL YEAR. FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR- FIREMAN'S UNDERSELL SO WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO BEGIN THINKING
ABOUT IT SOONER THAN THAT- AND
THEN AS WE LOOK AHEAD TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REFLECTED THERE IS
STILL ROOM AT ABOUT FIVE POINT
SEVEN BILLION. AND MEANING THAT
THE APPROPRIATION- HE'S
PROPOSING IN TOTAL- THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THE LIMIT WOULD BE
BELOW THE LIMIT BY THAT AMOUNT
BUT ALSO I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO PROPOSING
AROUND TWELVE BILLION IN
PROPOSALS THAT REDUCE REVENUES
FOR OUR APPROPRIATION CENTERS
THAT ARE- EXEMPT FROM THE LIMIT
SO IN OTHER WORDS- THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT TOO- HAVING THIS ROOM.
UNDER THE CELL. REALLY OVERALL
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TWENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THAT THAT
I WAS TALKING ABOUT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAS ABOUT
SIXTEEN BILLION IN PROPOSALS
THAT ADDRESS DEL REQUIREMENTS
AND THEN ANOTHER THIRTEEN
BILLION THAT ARE- PROPOSALS THAT
ARE NOT EXCLUDABLE FROM THE CELL
THOSE INCLUDE- NINE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN SPENDING AND THEN
THREE. BILLION IN- ENOUGH THAT
THE- DISCRETIONARY RESERVE AN FF
B. U. WHICH- HAS HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT. IS ACTUALLY IT'S NOT X.
EXEMPT FROM THE CELL THAT COUNTS
TOWARDS THAT FELT SO. ONE OF
THIS MEANS THAT. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE LEGISLATORS RANGE OF
CHOICES ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. BROADLY SPEAKING IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE LIMIT. TO KEEP
APPROPRIATION BUT BELOW THE
LIMIT IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. ANY OF THE SIXTEEN
BILLION IN SALIX GOOGLE PROPOSAL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO
REJECT. REALLY SHOULD THINK
ABOUT REPLACING THOSE WITH OTHER
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE ALSO SALIX
BOOTABLE FOR THEIR SOME
LIMITATION ON YOUR FLEXIBILITY
THERE. ON THE OTHER HAND ANY OF
THE THIRTEEN BILLION THEY'RE
ALREADY BEING PROPOSED IS NOT
EXCLUDABLE PROPOSALS FROM THE
GOVERNOR- AT THE LEGISLATURE
CHOSE DIRECT REJECT THOSE IN
REPLACE THOSE WITH OTHER
CHOICES. YOU HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT IT'S REALLY
THESE LARGER AMOUNTS YOU JUST
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT YOU
CAN'T VARY TOO MUCH FROM THOSE
LARGER AMOUNTS AND REMAINS-
UNDERNEATH THE CELL- AS IT'S
CURRENTLY. WORKS. SO NOW I'LL
MOVE ON TO. THE THIRD PAGE ARE
WE OFFERED SOME COMMENTS ON ON
SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
SPENDING PROPOSAL. AND HERE ARE.
YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF OVER
ARCHING REMARKS FIRST OF ALL
OVERALL WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT.
THEN THE GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
LAST YEAR'S COMMITMENT- THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FINANCE THIRTY
MENTIONED. IT IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO DEDICATE SOME
PORTION OF THE EARLY PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR TO
CHECKING END ESSENTIALLY ON HOW
THAT IS GOING HOW IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE CHOICES
GOING. OUT WITH THE ROLLOUT OF
THE FUNDING WORKING AND SORT OF
PERFORM PERFORMING BASICALLY
SOME AMOUNT OF AN OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION IN THAT PROCESS.
RELATED LINKS WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO
BE CAUTIOUS THEN ABOUT CREATING
NEW OR SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED-
EXISTING PROGRAMS- UST BEARING
IN MIND THAT STATE OVERALL
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT THESE. NEW
INITIATIVES. BANDANNAS THE
OVERALL COMMENT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR- THE RECOGNITION
ESSENTIALLY THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
STARTING TO APPEAR LIKE IT COULD
BE AN ONGOING OVER A LONGER TERM
ISSUE FOR US ALL TO DEAL WITH.
AND YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS RECOGNIZE THIS REALITY
AND YOU MAY HAVE- SOME
IMPORTANT- PREFERENCES TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT- AS YOU AS YOU KNOW
THINK ABOUT. THAT- PROSPECT- ON
THE NEXT TWO PAGES FOUR AND FIVE
I THINK I WILL- JUST.
ESSENTIALLY POINT OUT TO YOU
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS. A LIST OF
SEVERAL OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND SOME OF
OUR INITIAL CONTENT- UNDERNEATH
THEM I WILL NOT GO THROUGH ALL
OF THEM THEY'RE KIND OF IN
KEEPING WITH THE THEMES THAT I
JUST MENTIONED. BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL I JUST
WON'T GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM
WHAT I WILL SAY LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
THIS DID THAT TAKE ONE EXAMPLE
INDICATED FOURTEEN. AREA THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING- MANY
NEWPROGRAMS AND REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE MIDST OF- THE ONGOING
DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND THEIR CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT MORE NEW PROGRAMS IS
LIKELY LIMITED SO WE KIND OF HAD
THAT OVER ALL.CONTENT RECOMMEND
FINDING FEWER NEW PROGRAMS AND
PRIORITIZING THOSE THAT ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING PROBLEMS THAT
CANNOT BE ADDRESSED WITH- THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS SO IT'S KIND
OF THAT TYPE OF THINKING
APPLIED. SOMEWHAT ACROSS THESE
DIFFERENT AREAS IT WOULD BE MY
CONTENT. BY MOVING. IMAGE SIX OF
THE HAND OUT HERE JUST A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS ON THE STATE-
OVERALL BUDGET CONDITION. YOU
MAY RECALL THAT IN RECENT YEARS
WE HAVE DESCRIBED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REVENUE
ESTIMATE AS IS REASONABLE.
THOUGH THAT CAUTIOUS AND NOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SHOWS REVENUE
ESTIMATES THERE ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN BEFORE
OVER THE THREE YEAR BUDGET
WINDOW THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS RAISED ITS REVENUE ESTIMATES
BY FORTY ONE BILLION FROM THE
BUDGET ACT. MAKING THEM ACTUALLY
MUCH CLOSER TO WHAT WE CONSIDER
IT IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
REVENUE ESTIMATE. WE'VE KIND OF
DONE WE'VE DEVELOPED A RANGE OF
WHAT IS POSSIBLE. AND THERE AT
THE MINUTE IS NOW PRETTY CLOSE
TO OUR MEDIAN RANGE OUR OUR%
MEDIAN ESTIMATE WITHIN THAT
RANGE SO WE ARE REFERRING TO IT
AS THE MIDDLE OF THE ROAD AND
ARIEL. AS LIKELY YOU KNOW THIS
IS LIKELY TO BE AS- YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST AS LIKELY THAT
REVENUES WILL COME IN HIGHER IS
THAT IS THAT WILL THAT THEY'LL
COME IN LOWER ACCORDING TO OUR
BEST ESTIMATE. THAT SAME LOGIC.
SAME PROCESS APPLIES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION MULTIPLE YEAR
REVENUE ESTIMATES. AGAIN THEY
ARE REASONABLE- AND THEY'RE
SOMEWHAT HIGHER THAN BEFORE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MULTIPLE YOUR
REVENUE ESTIMATE. BUT AS WE
NOTED BEFORE- IF YOU ADOPT THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES THAT ARE
HIGHER- THEN THEY- INHERENTLY
ARE GOING TO BE LESS SUBJECT TO
UPWARD REVISION IN THE FUTURE.
YOU'RE ALREADY CAPTURING SOME OF
THAT UPWARD NASH IN THE INITIAL
ESTIMATE. IT'S REALLY BECOMES
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT
THE SPENDING PROPOSALS PUT
FORWARD BY THE ADMINISTRATION-
REALLY EXCEED. ITS OWN ESTIMATE.
OF THE STATE'S FUTURE BUDGET
CAPACITY THIS IS DEMONSTRATED IN
YOU LOOK AT THE ADMINISTRATION
MULTIPLE YEAR REVENUE- AND
MULTIPLE YEAR- GENERAL FUND
FORECAST. IT SHOWS THAT
NEGATIVE- SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY BALANCES IN
THE IN THE THREE YEARS FOLLOWING
THE BUDGET YEAR SO. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY ASSUMING THAT AT
SOME POINT ALONG THE WAY.
REVENUES WILL BE HIGHER THAN
WHAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY ESTIMATED
TO BE OR THAT EXPENDITURES WILL
BE LOWER SO. THAT'S SOMETHING TO
KEEP IN MIND- FINALLY ON THE
LAST PAGE HERE WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS ABOUT- THE PROPOSAL
ON ON- RESERVES. AND THE FIRST
THING I'LL JUST NOTE IS THAT WE
DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT OF- METHODOLOGY HERE
WE DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE
GENERAL PURPOSE RESERVES WHICH
AS I SAID WHERE THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT. THE SFU
THE SAFETY NET RESERVE. WE
DIFFERENTIATE THAT GROUP FROM
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT RESERVE-
THE- THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE IS VERY HELPFUL. FOR
MAINTAINING EDUCATION FUNDING IN
A DOWN YEAR- IT WOULD IT WOULD
PROVIDE A WAY TO- SUSTAIN
FUNDING FOR THE SCHOOLS AT A
CONSTANT LEVEL. BUT THOSE
BALANCES REALLY WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THE U. AT THE
LEGISLATURE OR OUR POLICY
MAKERS- IT WOULD NOT REALLY BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP YOU CLOSE AN
ESTIMATED BUDGET PROBLEMS. SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE REASON WE MAKE
THAT DISTINCTION. AND WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVE THEY ARE YOU KNOW
APPROACHING TWENTY FIVE BILLION
WHICH SHIP FROM A NOMINAL
STANDPOINT IS VERY I. AGREE I
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT AS A
SHARE OF THE STATE BUDGET WHICH
IS REALLY THE IMPORTANT WAY TO
LOOK AT IT. YOU CAN SEE THAT
THEY STILL REMAIN A LITTLE BIT
BELOW- WHAT THEIR LEVEL WAS
HIRED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC SO.
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO THINK
THAT- CONSIDERING HIGHER
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE IS
WARRANTED AND- SO WITH THAT I'LL
STOP HERE AND- I KNOW THAT ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
OFFICE WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MR BERWICK SAYS
ALWAYS A VERY GOOD OVERVIEW FROM
THE LA- AND ALSO OF COURSE-
THANK YOU CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR-
ERICA LEAK. FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO LET ME TURN NOW. TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE QUESTIONS BEFORE WE CHECK
FOR EITHER THE LA- OR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. SO LET'S SEE I'VE
GOT MISTER CORTESE MISCON LAGER
MR PAN. HI MR LAYERED COLLEGES
WOULD YOU WERE YOU STANDING UP
TO SHOW ME THAT YOU WANTED TO. I
COULDN'T- CHILL OF THE STANDING
UP WAS JUST TO STAY OUTDOORS SO
I WILL GET YOU ON THIS LIST. BUT
LET ME FIRST TURNED TO MY VICE
CHAIR- SENATOR NELSON DID YOU
HAVE A COMMENT QUESTION AND THEN
I WILL GO TO NO OKAY SO- WE WILL
GO. TO SENATOR CORTESE SENATOR
COM LAGER SENATOR LAYERED
SENATOR PANTS AND A WHITE CAT
SCAN. THANK YOU MA'AM SURE- IN
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF OUR
PRESENTERS WERE- AN EXCELLENT
JOB. OF GIVING US AN OVERVIEW
AND I HAD A- CHANCE I'M SURE
LIKE. MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
REVIEW SOME OF THE MATERIALS YOU
WERE DRAWING FROM- JUST NOW- THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS FOR THE LA- I
WAS WONDERING IF HE- WOULD
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT MORE. ON THE
COMMENT- IN A EIGHT EXCUSE ME
FOR PARAPHRASING ESPECIALLY FROM
AN ACCURATE BUT THE COMMENT
ABOUT. A GOING BACK IN AND
LOOKING AT PROGRAMS- THAT WE
CREATED- IN THE VERY RECENT
PAST- FOR THE NEED FOR
AUGMENTATION I THINK IS WHAT YOU
WERE REALLY REFERRING TO THERE
BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO CLARIFY F
YOU COULD JUST GIVE EXAMPLES OF
THOSE- I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT PAID SICK LEAVE RIGHT
NOW- ALTHOUGH THERE. IS A JUST A
PROGRAM WE CREATED ACTUALLY
SUNSET ID- LANDLORD TENANT.
WHICH YOU KNOW APPEARS TO. BE
RUNNING NOW BASED ON SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE BECAUSE I NOTICE YOU
COMBINE THAT COMMENT WITH AN EYE
TOWARD. COPE WITH BEING HERE FOR
A WHILE- OR OR IS IT SOMETHING
ELSE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING GETTING THE RIGHT
GUIDE POSTS FROM YOU AS TO WHAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR KATIE-
THAT YES THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I WAS REFERRING JUST- TO THE
FACT THAT IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES STARTED
AND WE DON'T HAVE IN SOME IN
SOME CASES IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE BUDGET FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
YOU KNOW COMPLETE UP TO DATE
IDEA OF HOW THINGS ARE GOING IN
KIND OF ROLLING OUT SOME OF
THESE INITIATIVES AND
IMPLEMENTING. SOME OF THE
INITIATIVES THAT HAD STARTED
WERE LIKEWISE HOW THEY WOULD
COORDINATE OR COMPLIMENT REALLY
SOME OF THE NEW INITIATIVES THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PUT FORWARD THIS
YEAR WHICH HAVE. IN SOME CASES
THAT'S SIMILAR. FOUNDING EXCEPT
THE SIMILAR SOUNDING- GOAL- THE
- GOVERNOR PROPOSES ENCAMPMENT
CLEAN UP WE PUT FORWARD LAST
YEAR ABOUT FIFTY MILLION TO
THAT- TO THAT GOAL AND- THE
GOVERNOR IS NOW PROPOSING-
BELIEVE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
THAT AND SO IT'S A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE I THINK
MANY OF US WOULD AGREE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT- PROBABLY AN IMPORTANT
AND NEEDED. ACTIVITY TO
ACCOMPLISH BUT- WE DON'T HAVE AT
THIS POINT REALLY GREAT INSIGHT
TO HOW WELL HAS IT GONE WITH THE
FOR THE FIRST ROUND LAST YEAR OF
THE FIFTY MILLION DID. HAS THAT
MONEY GONE OUT A DATE- YOU KNOW
YIELDED THE RESULTS WE HAD HOPED
FOR- SIMILARLY THE GOVERNOR LAST
YEAR THERE WERE AROUND TWENTY
DIFFERENT WORK FORCE- PROPOSALS
RELATED TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
. AND IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S PUTTING
FORWARD AROUND TWENTY MORE
SOMETIMES FROM DEMO DIFFERENT.
DEPARTMENT AND IN SOME CASES THE
OBJECTIVE BEING VERY SIMILAR ON
THE SURFACE AND SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO AND YOU KNOW. TO BE
FAIR. WE STILL BILL YOU KNOW
THIS IS SOMEONE OF OUR INITIAL
REACTION TO THE PROPOSAL SO
WE'RE STILL GOING THROUGH SOME
OF THIS BUT I THINK WE'RE TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WELL. HOW DOES THE
FIRST ROUND GONE WHY WOULD WE DO
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY THIS YEAR
EVER LED BY DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT. AND YOU KNOW- SO
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF THE SPIRIT
IN WHICH I WAS MAKING A COMMENT
SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IN THE
END I SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND
THAT DOES SEPARATE OUT A LITTLE
BIT- SORT OF BUT PERHAPS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PROGRAMS.
LIKE LITTER CLEANUP VERSUS- SOME
OF THE COVERT IN EARLY ACTION
ITEMS THAT WE DID LAST YEAR IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME ALL. ALL
STOP THERE BUT IT WILL BE GOOD
TO CONTINUE TO GET- YOUR
SPECIFIC THOUGHTS- AS THIS
BUDGET PROCESS CONTINUES IN
TERMS OF WHERE THIS
IMPLEMENTATION- REPORTS. ORDERED
ITALIAN RATIONS ON OUR PART
SHOULD TAKE PLACE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE AND THEN I SEE
IN MY REMOTE THAT SENATOR DRAWS
ON SENATOR STERN. AND SENATE NOW
SENATOR RICHMOND HAS HER MIKE UP
TO SO LET ME JUST GO TO THE LIST
REALLY QUICK. WE'RE GONNA GO COM
AUGER LAYERED PAN RIGHT CASKEY
DRUGS OR STERN ECKMAN GO AHEAD
SENATOR CALM WATER. SHARE AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK- IN ADVANCE
RIGHT NOW- BUDGET STAFF- FOR THE
WORK THEY'VE ALREADY DONE AND
THE WORK THAT THEY WILL BE
DOING. DURING THIS BUDGET SEASON
SO I'M SAYING THANK YOU RIGHT
NOW BUT I WILL COME BACK AND SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN- AT THE END OF
THIS I HAVE A QUESTION FOR- LEE
L. A. O. I. NOTICE THAT- AND I'M
ALSO STILL DIGESTING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BECAUSE IT'S
ROBUST- HE HAS- THE BUDGET
ALLOCATES QUITE A BIT OF MONEY
FOR- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS AND MY
QUESTION IS- I'D LIKE YOUR
THOUGHTS. ON IF IT MAKES SENSE
FOR US TO KIND OF CREATE AN A
WELLNESS PACKAGE ON HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ACROSS THE
STATE OR DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO
KIND OF HAVE THOSE DOLLARS
INFUSED ACROSS THE VARIOUS-
DEPARTMENTS OR AGENCIES OR ISSUE
AREAS. WE WANT TO FIND- BECAUSE
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
PERMEATING YOU KNOW EVERY WALK
OF LIFE- AND WANTING TO KNOW
DIFFERENT OTHER- APPROACHES TO
HOW WE CAN MAYBE ADDRESS THIS I
CERTAINLY THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE. FOR A
WHILE FOR US- AND THEN MY SECOND
QUESTION TO JUST ATTACK ON TO
MY- WHAT DOES SENATOR CORTESE
ASKED IS KIND OF THOUGHTS ON.
THAT D. OUT WE KNOW THAT A
NUMBER OF WELL SO LET ME JUST
ASK THE FIRST QUESTION OKAY. FOR
ADULTS TO LSU YEAH. OKAY YES
WELL I MEAN THE FIRST THING I
MIGHT SAY IS THAT WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GO THROUGH SOME OF
THESE IN MORE DETAIL- I THINK I
GOT THE GIST OF YOUR QUESTION
BUT I MIGHT ACTUALLY- TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE- MARK NEWTON DID SEE
IF- IF. HE HAD SOMETHING MORE
SPECIFIC AT ALL. THE BIG
QUESTION- THAT YOU YOU RAISED.
SOME NEAT. YES GOOD GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MARK NEWTON- WITH THE
LA- CAN IT MIGHT BE HER YES
YOU'RE BEING HURT VERY GOOD YES
THE SENDER BREEZES A UP. A LOT
OF VERY IMPORTANT PART AND SHE'S
BEEN IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTEXT AND WHAT IS TRUE IS THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- IS VERY BIFURCATED IN
TERMS OF THE DELIVERY AND I
THINK IN IN RECENT YEARS-
THERE'S BEEN AN EFFORT TO SEE.
TAKE A MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
THE TO THE ISSUE AND- IN
RECOGNIZING THAT THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONNECTION WITH THAT
WHICH WE CALL THROUGH THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND- AND
HOMELESSNESS AND- SO I THINK THE
BEAT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL DOES
REFLECT. PROPOSALS THAT REFLECTS
THE OVERALL TO REVIEW THERE
STILL IS THE ISSUE OF
IMPLEMENTATION BY- VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS AND- AND I THINK
THERE'S ROOM FOR- ONLY HELPS
EVEN MORE COORDINATED APPROACH
BUT I THINK THE- THE LEGISLATION
ADMINISTRATION ARE MOVING MORE
STRICT IN THAT DIRECTION THERE
IS A VERY VERY MAJOR
INVESTMENTS- LAST YEAR IN IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THE SERVER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ARE JUST
BEGINNING AND- GOT A SENATOR
MENTIONED ANYTHING VERY
IMPORTANT TO MONITOR. THE
PROGRESS OF THOSE INVESTMENTS AS
WELL AS IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES THERE'S NEW MONEY
THIS YEAR TO SIGNIFICANT SET NEW
INVESTMENT IN SORT OF BRIDGE
HOUSING- BUT SET AT ALL ONLY NO
I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT AS
YOU ALLUDE TO. LOOK AT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICE AS A- AND YOU
SHOOT THAT CUTS AROSS A NUMBER
OF POLICIES THROUGH VARIOUS IN A
IN THE- IN- IN STATE GOVERNMENT
AND WORKING TOWARDS THAT-
THROUGH A. MORE CORNY.
INVESTMENTS ARE- TO THE MOST IN
. WAY OF ADDRESS THAT ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE BUT WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON ON EVALUATING
ISSUES. ALL RIGHT LET ME TURN
THEN TO- SENATOR LAYERED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF WHO BECAUSE
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ARE
HEARING TIME IS ABBREVIATED SO
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK ONE
QUESTION OF FINANCE IN THE
ALLEY- AND JUST LET THEM KNOW
THAT FAR TIME WISE ABBREVIATED.
I WOULD HAVE WANTED TO DRAW THEM
OUT ON THE TEACHER SHORTAGE THAT
EXISTS AND SUBSTITUTE SHORTAGE
ON THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNOR
REGIONALLY SAID HE WANTED TO BUY
DOWN PERSON STIRS WITH SOME OF
THE- A- SURPLUS AND SEE IF
YOU'RE STILL INTERESTED IN THAT.
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE AND PRE K.
T. K. IS EXACERBATED FACILITIES
ISSUES AND HOW WE'RE GONNA DEAL
WITH SCHOOL FACILITIES ISSUE.
AND THEN THERE'S A PROPOSAL FOR
TUITION THAT'S DIFFERENT BETWEEN
UC AND CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ARE ONE OF WE WILL
LIKELY HAVE ROUGHLY TEN HEARING
STARTING IN EARLY FEBRUARY AND
JUST HEADS UP WILL ASK ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES IN THE HEARING. THE
ONE QUESTION I WANTED TO ASK OF
FINANCE AND THEN- HAVE THE
VALET- COMMENT. IS ENROLLMENT AT
K. TWO TWELVE WAS DECLINING
BEFORE. THE PANDEMIC AND THAT
DECLINE HAS BEEN EXACERBATED AND
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES A THREE
YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE OF IT. AS A
WAY TO DEAL WITH FUNDING BUT
IT'S CREATING A CLIFF. AT. WE
MIGHT DO ABOUT SCHOOL FINANCING
RELATED TO EIGHTY A AND- THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE AND SO
IT JUST DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTEMPLATE THAT THIS REALLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE AND HAS
OTHER THINGS THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT AND WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DONE.
COMMENTING WITH THE LA- OFFERED
THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON THIS I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR THERE TO
THAT QUESTION- SO BASED ON THE
CURRENT HOLD HARMLESS- THE CLIFF
WOULD HAVE OCCURRED- NEXT YEAR
AND I THINK THAT'S THE IDEA OF A
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE TO
USE- IN REGARDS TO EDA- IS TO
PREPARE OR ALLOW FOR THE
TRANSITION FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TOOK HER. OVER THE PERIOD OF
THIS YEAR SO THAT SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WERE IN
OUR THAT OUR RE IN A- SITUATION
IN REGARDS TO DECLINING. EXTRA
TIME. BASICALLY HAVE AN YEAR TO
ALLOW TO- BUT APPS RIGHT- PRE
PANDEMIC THERE WERE DECLINES IN
ENROLLMENT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY. THE PANDEMIC AND
SO THIS PROPOSAL IS TO REALLY
GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS MORE TIME
TO PLAN. THANK YOU AND SENATOR
DAVE ANOTHER F. AND I ALSO ASKED
THE LA- TO COMMENT ON THE
CONTENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEANT A GREAT. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR STAFF AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO- GOING INTO GOING INTO THE
VISUAL DETAIL THAT YOU MENTIONED
IN THE UPCOMING HEARINGS BUT-
YEAH I THINK OUR UNDERSTANDING
AT A HIGH LEVEL AND ALL THAT AND
YOUR MY COLLEAGUE- AND- DEPUTY
OF THE- K. TWELVE- UNIT TO WEIGH
IN AS WELL BUT- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. BE CLEAR.
THAT YOU REFERRED TO WITH MUCH
MORE OF AN ISSUE BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT-
OR A CURRENT LAW. BUT UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL IT
WOULD BE- MITIGATED. WHAT BUT
LET ME LET ME PASS IT TO EDGAR I
THINK YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
OPERATE DIGITAL- DETAIL FOR YOU. GOOD MORNING ENTER CONTROL THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
IT'S JUST A COMMON COMING OF THE
SHIPPING CLERK- UNDER CURRENT
LAW AND WE WOULD EXPECT WE DON'T
HAVE WE DON'T HAVE CURRENT YEAR
ATTENDANCE INFORMATION QUITE YET
WHICH- LIQUOR YOUR ATTENDANCE
INFORMATION IS WHAT. WOULDN'T
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT
MONSTER BUT NEXT YEAR BECAUSE OF
THIS BECAUSE THE KING. CLINICAL
PROVISIONS THAT. COULD CREATE.
FINDING FOR SCHOOL DOES AND THE
GOVERNMENT WITH THINK ADDRESS.
THAT ISSUE BY A COMMA YOU. IN
PREVIOUS YEARS OF ATTENDANCE SO
THAT THERE WOULD SOME
CALCULATION OF. THE TENANTS THAT
INCLUDES PRE PANDEMIC NUMBERS
THAT WILL SMOOTH IT OUT I THINK.
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT THE
PROPOSAL TO GIVE YOUR PHONE MORE
COMMENTS OR SOMETHING- BUT- IT
DOES SEE LIKE THE PROPOSAL
WOULD. OVER TIME THANKS IT'S
GOING TO BE A DECLINE IN IN THE
IN ATTENDANCE OVER TIME SO THE
CLINTON. HEALTHCARE FUNDING BUT
IT WOULD BE MORE DRAWN OUT AND
IT WOULD BE SLOWER OVER THE
PERIOD. FIFTY ADDRESSED THAT
ISSUE IT BECOMES LIKE WHETHER
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH OR ONE
OF THEIR OWN AT THE STILL
LOOKING INTO IT WE'LL HAVE MORE
ON COMMENTS YOU WE HAVE OUR-
SINCE WHEN YOU'RE IN- BUT PUT IT
SOMETHING THAT THE TO THE DRESS
THAT PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
ATTENDANCE WE DON'T ENROLLMENT
HAS BEEN DECLINING- HAS BEEN
DIRECTED TO DECLINE AT A FASTER
RATE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WE
SAW NOTHING THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO DATA TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT-
STATEWIDE DATA TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF WHAT ACTORS CONTINUE.
FROM INITIAL. REPORTS FROM HEARD
AFTER ME. THE BATHROOM. THANK
YOU SIR LET ME TURN NOW TO
SENATOR PANTS I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCING A
QUESTION FOR L. A. L. AND AGAIN
PRECIADO PRESENTATIONS- AND I'VE
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
DELVING INTO MORE DETAIL. ON
SPECIALLY HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AND BUDGETS OF THREE AND JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR- MAINTAINS COMMITMENT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH WITH THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION AND THIS YEAR
WITH THE ON GOING COMMITMENT FOR
THREE HUNDRED AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED MILLION EVERY YEAR
THEREAFTER- I DID HAVE A GO AND
AGAIN ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING FORWARD TO
HEALTH FOR ALL MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR ALL BUT I DID HAVE A
QUESTION- WHY IS THIS NOT GONNA
TAKE WAYS WHERE WE BLAME. THE
IMPLEMENTATION TILL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING I THINK THIS
SPRING WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING
THE SENIORS- BUT I'M STRAIGHT
UNDERSTAND AS TO WHY THE-
OPPOSING THE WAY TO. TWENTY
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO DO A LITTLE
EARLIER- ESPECIALLY SEVERE
PANDEMIC SO WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO NEED HEALTHCARE COVERAGE YOU
NEED HEALTH CARE- AND- SO
PERHAPS FINANCING FINANCE
ADDRESS THAT THE ISSUE. SORRY
THANK YOU SENATOR PAT- YES
YOU'RE RIGHT DH CS IS WORKING-
MANY PROGRAMS AT THIS POINT AS
HAS BEEN POINTED OUT. IN IN
REGARDS TO- FORMER INVESTMENTS
BUT SPECIFICALLY ON THE FIFTY
PLUS. EXPANSION AND THAT WILL BE
THIS. I THINK SEEING THE CLUB
BASICALLY THE LONG RUNWAY- THAT
IT WILL TAKE BE-
ADMINISTRATION'S REALLY SIXTY
SUCCESSFUL AT DELIVERING THIS
PROPOSAL- PART OF IT IS STILL
ALLOW FOR- SYSTEMS TO BE READY
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS. IS SUCCESSFUL SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE LONG RUN. OKAY I WOULDN'T
MENTION OUR EXPERIENCE BOTH WITH
THE- USE THAT UNDER TWENTY SIX
AND THE OTHER FIFTY I MEAN AND
FACT BE ABLE TO GO OUT TO PEOPLE
AND SAY WE CAN COVER EVERYONE
INSTEAD OF BY PIECES ACTUALLY
WOULD BE SIMPLER. SO I'M NOT
SURE WHY THE BIG LONG RUNWAY SO
NECESSARY IT'S NOT LIKE WE
HAVEN'T DONE THIS BEFORE BUT- I
APPRECIATE THAT HOPE TO DELVE
INTO THAT A LITTLE MORE I ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT. THEY DID
RECOGNIZE YOU DIDN'T SAY IT WAS
A MONEY ISSUE TIMING WISE BUT I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT- WE
WERE NOT RENEWING THE MCO TAX
WHICH WOULD BE A POTENTIAL
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR- X.
MEDIKAL EXPANSIONS AS WELL SO.
LOOK FOR THE DELVING INTO. THE
OTHER QUITE I HAVE IS IN AGAIN
PC TO GOVERNOR PROPOSING.
INCREASES IN SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND MATT ACCOUNT EXPANSION. BUT
SERVE AS THE LA- MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF RESERVES WE'RE NOT
ADDING ANYTHING TO THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE. SO WELL CERTAINLY
WE DO HAVE THE ON THE NINE
HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEARS. AS WE ARE
INCREASING OUR COMMITMENTS AND
AN IMPORTANT WE DO SELL- TO TRY
TO SHIELD US FROM DOWNTURNS
DURING RECESSIONS- IS THERE A
REASON WHY WE'RE NOT AT. THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE. THIS YEAR-
I'LL JUST TAKE THAT ABOUT A HIGH
LEVEL IN REGARDS TO PRESERVE I
THINK THAT WE THAT RECENT
RESEARCH THIS IS A GOOD IDEA I
THINK WE ALSO ARE. TRYING TO
BALANCE INCREASED DEPOSITS INTO
THE RESERVES. AGAINST THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AND SO
ADDITIONAL DEPOSITS INTO
RESEARCH HOW AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE- NOT- WE
HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS TO. BUT
SOME THAT ARE GOING FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES- INTO THE RESERVES AS
AS A RESULT SO IT JUST REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE THAT BALANCE
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO. HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
BUDGET AS A LAUNCHING PAD FOR
DISCUSSION. AND HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS IN
THE SPRING OKAY NO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND BREAK NOTE THAT PERHAPS
AGAIN LIMIT WAS WRITTEN AT A
TIME FOUR YOU KNOW WHERE WOULD.
WE HAVE A YOU KNOW FORTUNATELY
WE ARE PUTTING RESERVE SO THAT
WE CAN KEEP OUR BUDGET STABLE
DURING. THAT TIMES AND MAYBE
THAT MEANS AN EXPLORATION OF- OF
WHETHER RESERVE SHOULD BE
COUNTED AGAINST THE AND LET ME
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE I KNOW THE
LEXUS IN LAW IS WHAT IT IS NOW
PERHAPS THERE'S AN IT SHOULD BE
AN EXPLORATION OF. HOW MIGHT
WANT TO TALK ABOUT MODIFYING IT
IN THE FUTURE AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS THE PUBLIC ABOUT
IT. SO APPRECIATE THAT- AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE SUPPORT SCHOOLS ARE
FIGHTING COATED- BUT DIDN'T
EXIST QUESTIONS FOR THE ALLEY OF
IS HE DID MAKE MENTION YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS ISSUE OF
LONG TERM. COVE IN NINETEEN
PLANNING AND I AGREE WITH YOU-
WE NEED TO. NOW THIS IS SERVICE
YEAR OF ABOUT. IN YEAH WELL
THIRTY YEARS OF PANDEMIC AND-
WE'RE REALLY THINKING ABOUT BUT
STARTING TO THINK ABOUT LONG
TERM SO I GUESS MY QUESTION FOR
THE LA- IS THAT- WHEN USED IN
WHEN YOU SEARCH A LONG TERM
COVERED PLANNING THANK YOU SIR
MAYBE ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT ON
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING I'LL JUST
SAY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT. ONE IS THAT-
COLD IT'S NOT GOING TO GO AWAY
NOW HOPEFULLY WE'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE SURGES LIKE WE'RE SEEING
THIS YEAR INVESTORS SAW LAST.
MIKE IS THAT ON TOP OF FLU AND
OTHER THINGS THAT NORMALLY. WILL
INCREASE IN THE WINTER. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HOLD IT ON TOP
EXACTLY HOW MANY. HOW LARGE IT
IS I DON'T KNOW BUT- CERTAINLY
IT'S GOING TO PUT PRESSURE ON
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SHOULD WE
BE MAKING INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS IN HOSPITALS AND
OTHER SO THAT. OTHERWISE WE KEEP
RUNNING OUT OF BEDS EVERY
WINTER- WITH EVERY TIME WE HAVE
ANOTHER COVERT SEARCH. SO CELL
WAS IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT ME SAID
LONG TERM COVERED PLANNING
ANOTHER ISSUE IS THAT WE NO
LONGER HOLD IT. AS A PROBLEM.
CHILLED SO THAT WOULD MEAN
INCREASED INVESTMENTS AND THINGS
LIKE SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WE HAVE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF KIDS WITH
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
INFECTED CHILDREN DEVELOP LONG
CODES ARE PERSISTENT IMPACTS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT PREGNANT WOMEN
WHO GET COVE IT ARE MORE LIKELY
TO DELIVER I THINK THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DELIVER
PREMATURELY AND AGAIN THAT'S-
WITH PREMATURE- DELIVERY YOU CAN
HAVE. INCREASED RATES OF.
DEVELOPMENTAL AND OTHER.
DISABILITIES WHICH DON'T REQUIRE
AN ASSOCIATE MORE SERVICE AND
THE POLICIES BUT WE DO HAVE A
HEART STOPPER. OKAY OUT SO IT
ALLOWS THEM TO ELLIOT EASILY I
WILL OUT SO CAN YOU PLEASE
ANSWER. IN THAT IT TAKES
DELIBERATE ON WHAT YOU MEANT BY
LONG TERM CORPORATE PLANNING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAT
I MEAN IT'S REALLY. PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
WE COULD BE THINKING ABOUT AND-
AS YOU SAID I THINK WE'RE
BEGINNING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE-
CORBETT PANDEMIC IS NOT LIKELY
TO BE SOMETHING THAT WE YOU KNOW
DEFEAT. BEHIND THE ENTIRELY. AND
I RECOGNIZED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WAS DEVELOPED BEFORE THE
OMICRON- VARIANCE WAS FULLY
APPRECIATED SO THAT. THE
CHALLENGE BUT- JUST AS WE
CONTINUE TO COME TO TERMS WITH
THIS NEW REALITY I MEAN I THINK
WE'RE- WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
TYPES OF- INDIVIDUAL THE- WAR-
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER IT'S- THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OR SICK
WE- DID THAT MAKE SENSE TO DO
THEIR CURRENT STRUCTURE MAKES
THEM. FOR THAT OF AN ENDO
SITUATION- WHAT ABOUT THE SCHOOL
THAN TRACKING PROTOCOLS. AND
GUIDANCE SHOULD DO WE NEED TO DO
CHANGES TO THE WAY WE'VE BEEN-
YOU KNOW GUIDING THEM SO FAR ON
THAT FRONT- WHAT ABOUT- PRISON
CAPACITY IN OUR STATE PRISON. I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN IN OUR OFFICE IS
RECOMMENDED THAT THERE'S- THE
INMATE POPULATION TO GET TRENDS
TO GRASSROOTS CLOSE FACILITIES
BUT- DID THAT CHANGES WE NEED
TO- HOUSE B. AND MAKING A LEFT
THEN ARRANGEMENT BECAUSE OF BY
THESE KIND OF- VIRUSES SO. IN
THAT CASE MAYBE IT CHANGES OUR
OUTLOOK FOR THE PRISON CLOSURES-
CHILD CARES YOU ALLUDED TO
CHILDCARE IS I'D CERTAINLY. AN
IMPORTANT- COMPONENT ARE A CON
IN THE- SIDE OF OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR LABOR FORCE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
INFLATION PROBLEM AND SO IF YOU.
HAVE MANY WORKERS THAT ARE
SIDELINED BECAUSE THEY ACTED YOU
KNOW PROVIDE CHILDCARE BECAUSE
OF SIDE CLOSURES IN- YOU KNOW
PRESCHOOL OR DAYCARE. THEN YOU
SAID THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO RESPOD TO THAT SO IT
IS A QUESTION LIKE THAT I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT WE NECESSARILY
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS AT THIS
TIME BUT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE- THINKING
CAREFULLY ABOUT. THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES AS WE GO FORWARD IN THIS
BUDGET PROCESS. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU BOTH FOR SOME
IMPORTANT ISSUES. SENATOR Y.
CASKEY THAT'S GOING TO BE.
SENATOR DRAWS ARE SENATOR STERN
DIRECT ANCESTOR MEN. MANAGER ON
FILE ALL FOLLOW THE FINE EXAMPLE
OF THE CHAIR OF SEPT ONE ON
EDUCATION AND JUST GIVE A HEADS
UP MISS LEON TO FINANCE AND SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY
HAVE. LAST YEAR ON WILDFIRES IN-
PREVENTION RESILIENCY THE SENATE
PROPOSED A FIVE YEAR FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR SPENDING PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS. FOR PREVENT. THE
GOVERNOR HAS A TWO PROBE- WE
READ IN THE PAPER TODAY THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE PRESIDENT ON
THE FOR SERVICE AND TREATING THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY. BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SO WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING FOR
WHAT FUEL REDUCTIONS HAPPEN
AFTER. THAT WE'RE DOING HOW MANY
ACRES TO STATE STREET LAST YEAR
ARE WE ON TRACK WITH THIS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. ACRES ANNUALLY
THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
TREATING AND THIS HOW MUCH OF
THIS. YOU IN THAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING IS CRITICAL TOWARDS
FUEL REDUCTION IN THE DROUGHT
RICK ARENA WE'RE GOING TO- YOU
KNOW I'M VERY CURIOUS. BUT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY ALSO
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE DROUGHT
RESPONSE PACKAGE THAT WE DID
FROM THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
PACKAGE. HOW DID THE ACTIVITIES
THAT YOU COULD CONDUCT WITH THE
PROPOSED SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DIFFER FROM THOSE ON NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS EXTREME HEAT AND
COASTAL RESILIENCY WE HAD. A
GOOD DOWN PAYMENT LAST YEAR
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION BUT
THERE'S SOME OVER. PLEASE
SUBSCRIBE PROJECTS LIKE THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
AND THE URBAN A COMMITTEE FOR ST
YOU HAVE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
PROPOSED THERE. WE SEE WE
UNDERSTAND FROM THE RESTORATION
THAT THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION IN DEMAND FROM THAT THIS
IS SIMPLY THESE ARE TO LOWER THE
COST OF UTILITIES FOR THESE
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDE A MORE
HABITABLE COMFORTABLE LIVING
QUARTERS SO WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT.%
WHAT YOU CAN. CREATE INCREASING
FUNDING FOR L. W. I. P. ON THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I HAVE YET
TO SEE ANY PEACE B. C. P. CENTER
FOR MAINTENANCE IN THE RESOURCE
AREA. WE KNOW THAT THE BACKLOG
AT LEAST JUST IN THE PARKS WAS
ONE POINT TWO MILLION BUT- ALL I
SAW WAS FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR ART INSTALLATIONS SO
I GOT A QUESTION WITH THAT. AND
YOU KNOW I GUESS YOU HAVING
CONSERVANCIES THE SENATE HAD
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION THAT
WE WANT TO PUT A CONSERVANCY
STILL. TO THIS IMPORTANT CLIMATE
WORK YOU'VE GOT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IN OVER TWO YEARS TO BE
SPLIT BETWEEN FIVE CONSERVANCIES
AND- WERE THERE ANY LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED LAST YEAR. IN A ROW I
KASKY SORRY BUT ARE YOU GOING TO
HAVE ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT
EITHER THE LA- OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO RESPOND TO RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE TOP ON
THE FUEL REDUCTIONS HOW MANY
ACRES AT THE STATE STREET LAST
YEAR AND ARE WE ON TRACK TO MEET
THE GOAL OF FIVE HUNDRED.
MILLION ACRES ANNUALLY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GREAT LET'S HAVE
THEM. THAT AN FIRM IN FINANCE S.
THANK YOU THE COST CENTER I MEAN
IT'S NOT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE IN
OUR RESOURCES. MORNING STEVEN
BENSON APARTMENT FINANCE SENDIRI
CASKET FOR TRYING TO HAVE AN
EXACT NUMBER READY LEGAL FROM
THE NUMBER OF ACRES TREATED LAST
YEAR WILL DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP
WITH FOLKS YOU CAN GET THAT FOR
YOU BE READY FOR THAT- IN TERMS
OF BEING ON TARGET TO REACH THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE BALL
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OUR
CONVERSATIONS YOU HAD WITH
RESOURCES. AND OTHERS YES THAT
WE ARE ON TRACK TO DO THAT. ALL
RIGHT M. BUT THANK YOU CENTER A
CASTING FOR GIVING THEM THE
PREVIEW OF THE THING SHE WILL BE
EXPECTING WHICH- SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING START. SO NOW LET ME
TURN TO SENATOR DRAWS SO YOU'RE
ON THE REMOTE SO PLEASE JUST- I
THINK. YOU WERE ON MUTED SO
IT'LL GO AHEAD YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- COLLEAGUES-
I JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF ISSUES. BASED ON ONE
OF THIS. ONE OF THE YOUR
COMMENTS- AND THAT IS THAT WE
SHOULD PRIORITIZE THOSE- ISSUES
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS. UNDERLYING PROBLEMS-
LAST YEAR. FOUR MILLION WORKERS
WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE PAID SICK
LEAVE. AND THAT WAS BECAUSE OF
THE EMPLOYER THRESHOLD. WE'RE
TELLING WORKERS STAY HOME WHEN
YOU'RE SICK. BUT WE ARE NOT
SETTING UP THE RULES IN SUCH A
WAY THAT THEY CAN STAY HOME WHEN
THEY'RE SICK SO I'M VERY
CONCERNED- AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
THE GOVERNOR PUTTING A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE AS
AN ISSUE FOR EARLY ÒION
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE SIZE OF
THE EMPLOYERS THAT WOULD BE
COVERED- IT MIGHT MY DISTRICT
AND DRAW LOS ANGELES THERE'S-
PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES BUT I DON'T
MEAN SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE YOU
KNOW A HUNDRED OR TWO HUNDRED. I
MEAN A SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
REALLY EXIST FOR THEIR OWN
SURVIVAL AND SURVIVAL OF THE FEW
WORKERS THAT WORK FOR THEM- THE
SMALLER THE BUSINESSES AND THIS
IS JUST ME I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME BUT
IT'S LESS LIKELY THAT THESE
EMPLOYEES HAVE A SAFETY NET IS
LESS LIKELY IT'S MORE LIKELY.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE MINIMUM WAGE
IF AT ALL. BLACK LATINO AND-
WOMEN. API THEY'RE NOT LIKELY TO
HAVE DONE THE STIMULUS CHECK OR
ARE YOU I MEAN- WE'RE SETTING
THE RULES HERE ON TO EXCLUDE
THEM- AND THEN WE WONDER WHY
THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH- EQUITY
OUT WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE WHO
ARE POOR AND THOSE WHO. DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SO I
REALLY WANT TO- YOU KNOW. HOPEN
ASKED ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
THIS BECAUSE- YO KNOW 80% OF
ALL WORKERS- WORK FOR A BUSINESS
THAT'S LESS THAN TWENTY.
EMPLOYEES SO- AGAIN THIS I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE REACTING TO
EQUITY ISSUES WE ALWAYS START
TRYING TO COVER YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER THE FACT AFTER
PEOPLE DIE AFTER PEOPLE ARE
HOSPITALIZED. IN THESE
COMMUNITIES OF WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THE RULES IN ADVANCE SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION- ON THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE. AND SENATOR PAN'S
COMMENTS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
DRAWS OR DID YOU WANT EITHER LA
OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
RESPOND OR DID YOU WANT TO MAIL
MOSTLY LEAVE THOSE AS COMMENTS.
EACH OTHER MOSTLY IS COMMON AT
THEIR JUMPING OUT OF THEIR
CHAIRS AND THEY WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING. HE THE DEPARTMENT
STORE HAD IT YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS VERY INTERESTED IN
IT EARLY AFTER MARKETS ON LEAVE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AT THE LEGISLATURE
. THANK YOU. GREAT ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW TURN TO SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY COMING
THROUGH OKAY YES YOU ARE. OKAY
GREAT- MAKE COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS AND THEN JUST ONE
QUESTION- ONE ECHO- MY
COLLEAGUES' INTERCOM LOGGER
THERE ARE STILL UNPAID SICK
LEAVE IN A PRIORITY AIR AND
REALLY LOOKING. TO GO SMALL
ENOUGH FORCE WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN THEIR OWN HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND- THEIR LIVELIHOOD-
TEXAS SO HE DESTROYS WE
SHOULDN'T BE FORCING ANYBODY TO
MAKE RIGHT NOW- ALSO JUST A
QUICK COMMENT ON ON THE CLIMATE
BUDGET. THRILLED ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF THE ADDITION- THE GOVERNOR'S
SHOWN SO STRONGLY APPLAUD HIM
INTERESTED MINISTRATIONS FOR
GOING BIG EARRINGS A SMART TIME
TO BE SPENDING IN THAT KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. REGARDLESS WHEN
WASHED IN THE SINK DO I WOULD
JUST PUT A NOTE IN MY MIND
pABOUT APRIL TWENTY COMES TO
WILDFIRE ABOUT PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE HOW MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE ACTING NOT JUST ME ACRES ARE
WE TREATING- I JUST RAISE-
EXTREME HEAT IS A BIG
OPPORTUNITY ALSO IN BUILDING IT
RETROFITS AND THE HOTTEST PARTS
OF THE STATE WHERE PEOPLE ARE.%
SUFFERING AND OFTEN DYING IN IN
HEATING AND HEAT AFTER THAT
MAKES- THE THIRTY BY THIRTY PLAN
WE REALLY GOT A LOOK AT OUR
CONSERVANCIES AND USE THEM. FOR
ONE OTHER FINE. COMMENT FOR MY
IS- ON THE NEW HOME- AND SNACKS
AND- CARE REALLY HOPING WE CAN
STAY UP AND HELP. YOUR STAFFING
RATIOS READY AND PAY THOSE
WORKERS WHAT THEY DESERVE
BECAUSE THEY'RE PUTTING THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR SENIORS AND LOVED ONES.
ABOUT MY ONE QUESTION IS- TO ART
TO. ERICA OR SOMEONE A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THERE
ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
QUESTION I APPRECIATE CENTER COM
LONGER RAISING IT. HE'S BEEN
LEADING ON THIS AS WELL BUT YOU
ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT S. FOR HOW-
SEVEN Q. OR Q. CARE BEDS. OTHER
WORDS HOW HOW MUCH HOUSING THAT
pOUT OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET ACTION
BECAUSE I KNOW EVERY COUNTY IS
STARVING FOR- THOSE RESOURCES TO
GO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING ON
THE STREETS AND HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES. YOU KNOW IT'S
SORT OF AROUGH ESTIMATE OF- HOW
MANY KIDS DO YOU THINK WILL WILL
BE OUT OF THIS THIS BUDGET.
THANK YOU SENATORS I DON'T HAVE
THAT NUMBER WITH ME I'M GONNA
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE ADVERSITY
SEE IF YOU CAN FILL IN- IF NOT
WE CAN GET WE CAN GET YOU. AN
ESTIMATED FIGURE. THIS IS ADAM
GARCIA FINANCE YEAH I DON'T HAVE
THAT NUMBER OF BIDS IN FRONT OF
ME BUT ONCE YOU COME UP WITH.
OKAY THANKS. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN- LET ME TURN NOW TO
SENATOR EDMUND. BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE CENTER- AND THANK
YOU TO DR PAN WHO ASK THE
QUESTION I WAS GOING TO ASK ALSO
AROUND THE UNDOCUMENTED AND LIKE
WE COULDN'T JUST START ALL OF
THAT NOW ALTHOUGH ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO BRING UP
THIS ISSUE AROUND WORK FORCE
THAT I'M GLAD THE ADMINISTRATION
IS FOCUSING ON. AND WE KNOW THAT
AT WORK FORCE CONTINUES TO BE AN
ISSUE IN AS WE PROVIDE MORE
COVERAGE TO MORE PEOPLE AND WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO
MATCH THE SERVICES THAT WERE
PROMISING FOLKS- I WOULD BUY IT
SO THAT WAS MY- MY ONE QUESTION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO ORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE L. A.
O. ON DOING A LOT OF OVERSIGHT-
AS HAS BEEN PREVIOUSLY STATED WE
DID A- WHOLE LOT OF STUFF LAST
YEAR AND I THINK WE'RE WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE WERE. WE WERE AS A
BUILDING THE PLANE WHILE WE'RE
FLYING AND THEN THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO DO THE TUNE UP AND
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING'S OKAY. SO
WE'RE WORKING THAT INTO OUR
HEARINGS NOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOME OVERSIGHT- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ASKED FOR
LAST YEAR. IN REGARDS TO SENATOR
STERN QUESTION ABOUT. BUT THE
NUMBER OF BEDS NEEDED THAT WAS.
AND SO AS WERE AS WE'RE ARE
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES AND
PUTTING MORE MONEY OUT I THINK
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT THE
ANALYTICS AND THE DATA THAT
WE'VE COLLECTED. AND MAKING SURE
WE'RE- THAT. THAT THE MONEY
WE'RE SPENDING IS ACTUALLY GOING
WHERE WE WANT IT. THE DEPARTMENT
WAS ASKED TO COME UP WITH. AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT THE ACTUAL NEED
WAS IT WAS VERY HARD TO GET OUR-
ARMS AROUND NO ONE SEEMED TO BE
ABLE TO TELL US HOW MANY BEDS WE
NEED IT BUT THE WHOLE CONTINUUM
OF CARE. AND SO I KNOW. THAT WE
WERE ASKED FOR THAT AND WAS WAS
WE DO LAST. NOVEMBER I THINK IT
CAME OUT IN. JANUARY EARLY.
RECENTLY HE IS THERE SOMEBODY
WHO CAN SPEAK TO THE GAP THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY FACING- EIGHT.
IN THE AREA IN THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. IN THE EVALUATION THAT WA
DONE STATEWIDE. OF OUR OF OUR
COUNTIES. AND THEN. SO THAT
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION SO LET
ME HAVE- I THINK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. PRESS THAT. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SATURDAY
AGAIN I'M GOING TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE ADVERSITY FOR
SOMEWHERE TO TELL. YEAH THIS IS
ADAM WHO WAS THE FINANCE SIDE IS
VERY GOOD QUESTION- I'M NOT
AWARE OF THAT- WE HAVE THAT
NUMBER- BUT CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT- WE WILL LOOK INTO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S HARD TO
KNOW IF WE GET THERE IF WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY. WHERE WE'RE GOING-
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO TALK TO
TALKING FURTHER AND REALLY
LOOKING AT THAT DATA SEEING WHAT
WE'VE DONE WHAT'S OUT THERE WHAT
WE STILL NEED TO DO AND THEN.
HOW WE ACTUALLY CLOSE. THAT GAP-
AND ONE THING I WILL SAY- IN
REGARD TO HAVE SOME MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SPOKEN AT.
THE END WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HERE IT WOULD
BE A GREAT YEAR FOR A SPECIAL
SESSION ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN
THE CONTAINER OF CARE- WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT WAS IN HERE A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE YOU KNOW
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH. TO BE DONE
SO MUCH INTEREST IN IT THAT IT
IS VERY HARD TO DO IN THE IN THE
MIDST OF IT EVEN MORE COMING. ON
AS WE TRY TO JUGGLE WITHOUT A
REAL FOCUS ON THAT SO AGAIN JUST
TO. PUT IT OUT THERE IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
SPECIAL SESSION WILL BEGIN
ACTUALLY FOCUS ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN THE FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE- AS IT RELATES TO ALL OF
OUR- POPULATIONS AND THEN JUST.
AN OBSERVATION- AND- OF COURSE
WE KNOW THERE'S NO. CAUSATION OR
CORRELATION BUT I WILL JUST MAKE
AN OBSERVATION- THAT WHEN WE DID
AWAY WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
MENTAL HEALTH I BELIEVE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IS WHEN IT WENT
AWAY FOR GOOD- AND I WOULD JUST
OFFER THAT I DON'T KNOW THAT OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM HAS
IMPROVED. SINCE WE GOT RID OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
I LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
AGREED FOR THE QUESTIONS AND
ALSO FOR OF COURSE- ALERTING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID
DELEO WHOSE OFFICE WHAT. SOME OF
THE- QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE DELVING INTO YOU AS YOU START
YOUR HEARINGS- ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAD- SENATOR MEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR NIELSEN. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING A LITTLE DIFFERENT IN
THIS BUDGET- BUT OBVIOUSLY S. AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE POINTED OUT
THERE'S A LOT TO LIKE ABOUT
THIS- IN COURSE IS A GOOD
PROBLEM TO HAVE WHEN YOUR
DOCUMENT EXTRA FUNDS. I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE AND SENATOR STERN
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF TIME
INVESTMENT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ON INFRASTRUCTURE I
WAS ALSO REALLY PLEASED TO SEE A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT TAX CREDITS
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING- TO HELP
DEVELOP ROUTINE ARE INDEED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE U. SEES
FOR GREEN RD IN THIS IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS SO- YOU KNOW
I WAS PLEASED TO SEE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK. WHILE MANDATES
TO PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT MARKET
SIGNAL WE ALSO NEED TO KIND OF
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS
AND GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLIMATE ADAPTATION OF
DEVELOPMENT- I THINK PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR R&D IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL I'M ALSO PLEASED TO SEE
SO MUCH FUNDING GOING TO THE
BASE- INCREASES HERE FOR THE NEW
SEASONS YES USE- AS WELL AS THE
CAL GRANTS IN AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THE HEARINGS WILL HAVE ON
THAT AND BUDGET SUB ONE. MY
QUESTION HERE IS YOU KNOW IN
ANOTHER GREAT THING I THINK IS
BUT IT'S DOING IS IT'S PAYING
DOWN MORE OF OUR PENSION
LIABILITIES I AND- YEAH I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT JUST SO THAT WE
DON'T END UP WITH A PROBLEM DOWN
THE LINE AND WHAT WE WANT TO DO
WITH THE ONE TIME SURPLUS THE
KIND OF PAY DOWN OUR FUTURE
LIABILITIES ONE QUESTION I HAD
IS AN ALLUSION TO THIS IN THE
REPORT THAT WE RECEIVED IN LA-
SO THIS COULD BE L. A. O. OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT- I DID
IT BECAUSE OF INCREASED RETURNS
ON. THE STOCK MARKETS AND
WHATNOT THAT ARE DRIVING SOME OF
OUR TAX REVENUES- THAT WE SEEN A
DECREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
OUTSTANDING LIABILITIES- IN THE
PROJECTED RETURNS NEEDED TO
REACH- BREAK EVEN POINT I WAS
ONE OF EITHER YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THAT- DEPARTMENT FINANCER LA- AS
FAR AS WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN IN
CANISTERS AND PURRS ON A RATE OF
RETURN HAD. WE DO LAST YEAR AND
HOW DOES THAT IMPACT OUR LONG
TERM- PICTURE WITH HAWKING.
MIGHT I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER MEN AND ANY TO
THAT BOTH- HACKSAW RETURNS IN
THE 20% LAST YEAR SO STOP HERS
HAD ANY- TWENTY ONE POINT 3%
RETURN- AND STURRIDGE HAD EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN POINT 2% RETURN SO-
JUST IN IN REGARDS TO WHAT THAT
MEANS TO THE SYSTEM- AS AN
EXAMPLE HERS IS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY- SIXTY THREE BILLION
AND IT IS. UP PRIOR TO- FIVE DID
YOU KNOW THAT THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE POINT 3% INCREASE IT
WAS 70% AND NOW AFTER THE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT RETURN IT'S
GOING TO BE 80% SO THAT'S THAT'S
A- BOOK THAT THE POSITIVE
IMPACTS TO PURCHASE AND- I'M
STIRS THE STATION THAT WE HAVE-
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT
CONTRIBUTING ADDITIONAL PROP TO
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT. THE
ESTIMATES RIGHT. NOW IS THAT THE
STATE SHARE- HAPPEN. SO THOSE
ARE RESULTS OF THE WORK THAT
WERE FOR MONSTERS IF YOU NEED TO
THEIR INVESTMENTS EXACTLY. LIKE
A LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN. MR
PATRICK I SEE AT THE END OF. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR MAN AT THE
GOOD QUESTION AND THEN I THINK-
YOU KNOW THE THING THAT WE WOULD
JUST POINT OUT IS THAT. INTERNAL
BILITY CURRENTLY REPRESENT
SOMEWHAT OF A TRADE OFF THE
TENSIONS ARE GENERALLY IN BETTER
SHAPE AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FINANCE JUST SAD- AND SO THE
TRADE UP WE THINK IS PROBABLY
THAT. PUTTING MORE IN RESERVE IS
PROBABLY. A BETTER PLACE AT THE
MOMENT- THE HIGHER RATE OF
RETURN THEN IN CALPERS. ALLOWED
THE BIG HELPERS SIT IN TO TAKE A
STEP TO REDUCE ITS ASSUMPTION
WHEN IT COMES TO FUTURE RATE OF
RETURN WHICH IS PROBABLY. A YOU
KNOW A HEALTHY HEALTHY STEP- AND
SO IT THAT'S GOOD THE- ACTUARIES
ESTIMATE THAT THE CHARACTERS
LIABILITY THE STATE PORTION OF
THE LIABILITY. AS WELL AS JEFF
SAID WILL BE ELIMINATED WITHIN A
COUPLE OF YEARS. I DON'T WANT TO
GET TOO FAR INTO THE DETAILS IN
THIS DISCUSSION BUT I ACTUALLY
THINK THERE'S SOME CAUSE FOR
CONCERN. I WANT TO TAKE. THERE'S
SOME THING TO BE AWARE ABOUT
WITH THAT AND THAT IS THAT IF
THE CHARACTERS EIGHT LIABILITY
DOES BECOME ELIMINATED THE- NUL
CONTRIBUTION WILL WILL DECLINE
STATUTORILY. SUCH THAT THEN IN
THE FUTURE IF WE HAVE IT THE NEW
LIABILITY BECAUSE OF THE MARKET
DOWNTURN FOR EXAMPLE. WE WILL BE
CONTRIBUTING POTENTIALLY LESS
THAN IT NEEDED TO RETIRE THE
LIABILITY BY THE TWENTY FORTY
SIX- COOL SO- WE'VE WRITTEN A
REPORT ABOUT THAT AND- THINK IT
WARRANTS SOME LEGISLATIVE
ATTENTION. BUT IN GENERAL OF
COURSE THE HIGH RATE OF RETURN
THAT WERE EARNED BY THE SYSTEM
THIS YEAR IS A VERY POSITIVE
THING IF IT HAD PUT THOSE
SYSTEMS ON ON- BETTER FOOTING.
AND I DON'T I WILL ALSO JUST
NOTE THAT UNDER PROPOSITION TWO.
THERE'S ABOUT THREE AND A HALF
BILLION IN SUPPLEMENTAL
CONTRIBUTION GOING TO CALPERS
AND- IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL SO
THAT'S ALSO VERY FAVORABLE SO-
ANYWAY THE HOPEFULLY THAT'S
HELPFUL. IT THANK YOU SENATOR
MINUTE THANK YOU BARMOUTH
FINANCE AND- MR PADDOCK FOR LA-
FOR THE ANSWERS SENATOR NIELSEN
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF.
PRESENTS IT APPEARS THAT THERE'S
NOT MANY MANY CLOSURES THIS YEAR
I'M NOT SURE BUT IT APPEARS THAT
WAY. A POINT WAS MADE EARLIER
THAT. WE NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS.
WITH THE EPIDEMIC RAGING THROUGH
OUR PRISONS NOW THE HEALTH. IN
TERMS OF CLOSING MORE FACILITIES
AT PORT CLOSURES SOME OF THE
OPTIONS OF SPACE AND TREATMENT
THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE TO OUR
INMATES. IN OUR PRISONS. IN
TERMS OF THE- FORESTS WILDLAND
MANAGEMENT I'VE CHARACTERIZED AS
SUCH. I'D LIKE TO GET FEEDBACK
FROM THE RESOURCES AGENCY IF
FUNDS WILL BE DIRECTED. TOWARDS
COGENERATION IN OTHER WORDS A
SOURCE OF FACILITIES WITHIN
THOSE RURAL AREAS THE FORCE IN
THE WILD LANDS FOR BY SOME OF
THE FUEL CAN BE REMOVED. THROUGH
COGENERATION. SEEMS TO BE A
DEAFENING SILENCE ABOUT THAT.
AND ALSO AS WE DIRECT OUR
EFFORTS TOWARDS FOREST AND
WILDLAND MANAGEMENT. I ENCOURAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THE FOCUS ON
DIRECTING THOSE RESOURCES TO THE
MOST ACCOUNTABLE AND RESPONSIVE
AREAS THAT I THINK ARE HELPING
US MANAGE THOSE FORESTS AND
WILDLANDS. THOSE ARE THE
COUNCIL'S THAT ARE FORMED IN
EACH COMMUNITY. AND WHERE THEY
HELP US AND THEY SHOULD BE
HELPING DIRECT WHERE THOSE
RESOURCES ARE PLACED NOT JUST
THE RESOURCES AGENCIES. THE I
ALSO WOULDN'T TREAT AND THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE ASKED FOR A
SPECIAL SESSION ON HOMELESSNESS
. I'VE LONG ADVOCATED THAT IN
TERMS OF DEALING WITH THE
HOMELESS. WE NEED TO BE NOT JUST
PROVIDING SHELTER. BUT WE NEED
TO APPLY RESOURCES TO ADDRESSING
AND ASSESSING ASSESSING THE
NEEDS OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
. AND DIRECTING THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE HOMELESS IN THEPROPER
TREATMENT FOR HEALTH PHYSICAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH. IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE WE PAID MUCH ATTENTION
TO THAT IN THE PAST WE'VE
PROVIDE LIKE IN OUR HOME WAS
SEPARATE TO THE ABSTRACT ART.
COME INTO A ROOM WITH A TAKE
BACK AT THE END JUST START
SPLASHING ON THE WALLS BUT WE
REALLY NOT FOCUSED. ON WHAT WILL
BE THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
THE DEAL FOR THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AS IN IDENTIFYING
THEIR OTHER NEEDS NOW I
COMPLIMENTED THE GOVERNOR FOR AN
END TO THE DEPARTMENTS FOR
STARTING TO FOCUS A LITTLE BIT.
ON THAT NOW. THAT IT'S MORE THAN
JUST PROVIDING SHELTER OR AN
APARTMENT OR A- OFTEN ACQUIRED
FACILITY- HOLD HOTEL OR MOTEL.
AT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
RECOGNITION THAT ARE FOREVER
GOING TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS
WE'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH THE
HOLISTIC ISSUE. OF THE HEALTH
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH. AND
THE OTHER ADDICTION NEEDS AND
SUCH- THIS HOMELESS. POPULATION
THAT IS I THINK ENCOURAGING TO
ME IS THIS BUDGET IS
CONTEMPLATED. I HAVE A GREAT AND
DEVOTE TODAY OF THE RAINY DAY
FUND. AND I'D LIKE TO SEE US NOT
. DIMINISH THE IMPORTANCE. OF
THE RAINY DAY FUND. THAT WAS A
LONG TIME IN COMING. THE FINDING
OF THE RAINY DAY FUND. IN ONE OF
THE GREAT VALUES OF THE RAINY
DAY FUND HAS BEEN A BIT OF A
RESTRAINT ON SPENDING. EFFECTED
BY TAKING THOSE DOLLARS. WELL
BEYOND THE REACH OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO SPEND OR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SPEND. ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT DOES NEED TO BE
EXAMINED. THIS IS ABOUT THE
SHORTAGE OF JUDGES. THERE'S
TREMENDOUS AND I CONSIDERED VERY
NEGATIVE CHANGES GOING ON IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RIGHT NOW
RESULTING IN FAR FEWER
PROSECUTIONS. OR USERS OF THE
COURT REFERENCING HIS
REHABILITATION I PARTICULARLY
I'M TALKING HERE ABOUT THE COURT. WE NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT. AND IT'S A CURIOSITY TO ME
THAT WE ARE NOT TAKING A CLOSER
LOOK AT HIGH SPEED RAIL. THE
IMMENSE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE
HAVING TO MAKE TOWARDS THIS HIGH
SPEED RAIL. THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
IN ANY WAY IN THE FUTURE BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS WHERE THE
POPULATION IS. AND I THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE EXAMINED VERY
THOROUGHLY. IN THIS BUDGET. THE
SCREWED ME OF THE BUDGET AND THE
OVERSIGHT. ABILITIES OF THE
LEGISLATION THROUGH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I WANT TO COMPLIMENT
THE LEGISLATURE PUT TO THE
SENATE FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS OF ACCEPTING A GREATER
ROLE IN OVERSIGHT. OF THE
AGENCIES IN DEPTH OVERSIGHT. IN
CHANGING HOW THE AGENCIES THE
BUSINESS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO
HAVE A PROCLIVITY TO IS TO FORM
A NEW AGENCIES ALBEIT MAYBE
SMALLER ONES. BUT THERE SEEMS TO
BE A PROLIFERATION. ALMOST ALL
OF THESE WILL BUILD THE BASE. OF
OUR BUDGETS IN THE FUTURE.
TRADING EXPECTATIONS IN
OBLIGATIONS. I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO MADAM CHAIR PUT THOSE THINGS-
TO OUR ATTENTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON ALL
TAKE THOSE AS COMMENTS FOR- FOR
CON FOR US TO CONSIDER VERSUS
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO DIRECT
RESPONSE FROM EITHER LA OR DELAY
. CORRECT YES OKAY THANK YOU SO
LET ME GO TO SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM FOUGHT
CHERUB PJ THE OPPORTUNITY JUST
MINE ARE JUST COMMENTS I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT
WILL BE OBVIOUSLY HAVING
HEARINGS ON A LOT OF THIS- BUT I
REALLY WANT TO THINK- BOTH THAT-
FINANCE AND THE LA- FOR THE
DETAILED INFORMATION- I
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR
OVERSIGHT M. IN NEW PROGRAMS I
FEEL- THAT THE PROGRAM'S ROLLOUT
DIFFERENTLY IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE. AND THEY CREATE
SOME EQUITY ISSUES AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE- CONTINUE
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE
KNOW THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THE
HELP AND THAT. ALL COMMUNITIES
SHARE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
THOSE FUNDS- AND I'M SPEAKING
OBVIOUSLY OF THE RURAL- ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES REALLY HAVE A HARD
TIME ACCESSING SOME OF THESE
RESOURCES BECAUSE OF THAT-
CIRCUMSTANCES AND HOW THEY WERE
SET UP. AND I APPRECIATE THE
CAUTION ABOUT NOT STARTING ANY
NEW PROGRAMS AND UNTIL WE KNOW-
IF THE NEW MONEY THAT WE PUT ON
THE TABLE LAST YEAR IS- ACTUALLY
WORKING TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT. THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED NEED TO BE ARMED. A
SOFT AND- AND I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CONTINUED TRYING TO
CREATE NEW DEPARTMENTS BOARDS OR
DIVISIONS- IN BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE INSTEAD OF PUTTING
THEM THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEES IS BUILT. ON SO I'M
GONNA LOOK AT THAT PRETTY
CAREFULLY PART OF THE CHALLENGES
THEN WE DON'T KNOW REALLY HOW
THE PROGRAMS ARE GONNA ROLL OUT.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHALLENGE THEM IN
POLICY COMMITTEES. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THEY
ACTUALLY ARE ARE GOING TO WORK
ONE A SECOND WHAT WAS JUST SAID
ABOUT THE RAINY DAY FUND I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT.
ELEMENT IN OUR BUDGET AND- BOTH
OF THE LEARNING CENTER AND I
WERE AROUND DURING THE TIME THAT
WE MADE SOME OF THE WORST BUDGET
CUTS IN OUR- THE STATE'S HISTORY
AND- WE'RE PAINFULLY AWARE THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO THOSE DAYS- CLEARLY OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE DOING WELL.
BECAUSE INVESTMENTS IN THE STOCK
MARKET ARE DOING WELL OVERALL.
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR OUR
BUDGET BUT WHEN- THE ECONOMY
SOFTENS THAT'S WHEN WE START TO
SEPARATE WE'RE GONNA NEED-
THOSE. THOSE RESOURCES I ALSO
WANNA. ONE OF THE FOOTNOTES I
WANT TO SAY ON ON THAT CREATING
NEW PROGRAMS AND- AND- AND THE
CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT IN THE
AREA OF HOUSING- I THINK THERE'S
SOME REAL NEED FOR- SOME
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS. IN TERMS OF
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE ROLLING
OUT- AND A REAL. UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW WE'RE DOING IN TERMS OF
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS- WE PUT A
LOT OF MONEY OUT AND I'M NT
SURE WE'RE SEEING THE RESULTS OF
IT I'D LIKE TO HEAR THAT WE ARE
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN IT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I VISITED. AND
MANY OF THE SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS RESOURCES IN TO HELP
THEM WITH THEIR HOMELESS PROBLEM
AND FEEL LIKE THEY'VE BEEN LEFT
OUT OF THE GAME AND NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO IS ANYTIME WE
INVEST MONEY IN DOWNTOWN M.
INFILL. THE PROJECTS WERE GOING
TO GO ABOVE. TWO STORIES THE-
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ROBUST. PUBLIC SAFETY EQUIPMENT.
REQUIRE NEW PUMPER TRUCKS AND SO
THEY'RE CONSTRAINED TO ONLY
BUILD UP TO TWO STORIES INSTEAD
OF GOING HIGHER AND I THINK. SO
AS A CONSEQUENCE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS THE FUNDS MY POINT AND
ALL OF THAT IS THAT WE HAVE SOME
BARRIERS. AND I'M NOT SURE WE'RE
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION HOW TO
GET AROUND THOSE BARRIERS ARE
HOW TO SOLVE THEM. AND THAT'S
THE- PURPOSE OF HAVING POLICY
COMMITTEES. THAT CAN INVITE.
INFORMATION FROM OUR OUR
PARTNERS THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES AND WE CAN DO IT RIGHT
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO AND-
BEFORE I TURN TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- I THINK MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE. OUR
RECOGNIZED THAT WHILE WE HAVE
ANOTHER HEALTHY REVENUE YEAR.
THAT WE APPROVED- SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
SPENDING ON NEW PROGRAMS LAST
YEAR AND WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THOSE ARE. BEING ABLE
TO BE DELIVERED AND SO THAT
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION THAT WE ALSO
HAVE IN ADDITION TO. BRING THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US THAT OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION SO WE HAVE A LOT ON OUR
PLATES FOR THIS YEAR. AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN INCORPORATE SOME OF
THAT OVERSIGHT IN OUR HEARING
PROCESS BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT AND YOU FALL RACING
VERY LEGITIMATE- QUESTIONS. I'M
NOW BUT- WE- I AM HESITANT. I
THINK WE WILL GO TILL TWELVE TEN
JUST TO ALLOW AT LEAST FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAD
A HARD STOP OF. TWELVE BUT I
THINK WE COULD EXTEND IT FOR THE
TEN MINUTES BUT LET'S MODERATOR
PLEASE- YOU COULD Q. FOLKS UP IN
LET'S TAKE FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN THE QUEUE TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. RIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN NUMBERS THEN SWEAT
NAUSEA WITH THE QUALITY CENTER A
NONPROFIT FOCUSED ON ACHIEVING
DECARBONIZATION THAT'S BIG
ENOUGH TO KILL- AS WE ENTER
ANOTHER STRONG YEAR WITH THE
STRONG SURPLUS WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STRONG OCUS ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREA THE TRANSPORTATION NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS AND ENERGY. ONE
THING THAT WE NOTICED WAS NOT
THE TYPICALLY ADDRESSED IN THE
ENERGY PROPOSAL HOWEVER WITH THE
NEED TO FIND COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCE TACKLE CLIMATE DRIVEN
GREAT OUTAGES. OB AS WE LOOK FOR
WE URGE THE STATE TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO PUT
TOGETHER ENERGY RESILIENCE PLANS
THAT LEVERAGE CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES THE ELECTRIC
OUTAGES. YES ALLOCATION OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR ANY
REASON AND FINDING THE PENTAGON
FOR PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION.
FOLLOW UP THROUGHOUT. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CONFERENCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. HOLD ON BEFORE YOU
READ BECAUSE I FORGOT TO IGNORE.
OUR PERSON IN THE GALLERY WE
WILL TAKE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM OUR PURCHASE FROM THE
GALLERY AND THEN WILL RETURN
BACK TO YOU PHONE MODERATOR.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THREE QUICK ITEMS IN THE IN ONE
MINUTE. OF THE FIRST AS WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S- YOU I.
PAYMENT OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS.
IT'LL BENEFIT THE STATE WHO'S ON
THE HOOK FOR INTEREST PAYMENTS.
AS WELL AS EMPLOYERS WHO WILL
HAVE TO PAY A PER EMPLOYEE TAX
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S TAX
CONFORMITY PROPOSAL ON THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION- FUND
GRANTS SO THAT STATE RESTAURANTS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO STATE TAX. AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO ELIMINATE THE CAP ON BUSINESS
CREDITS. AND THE SUSPENSION ON
THE N. O. L. DEDUCTION AND THEN
THE THIRD ITEM IS ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE WE
DO HOPE IT WOULD BE PROSPECTIVE.
THAT IT WOULD ENSURE PUBLIC
ENFORCEMENT RATHER THAN PRIVATE
ENFORCEMENT THROUGH PAGA- THAT
THERE IS IN FACT A SMALL
BUSINESS CARVE OUT AND JUST KEEP
IN MIND MADAM CHAIR THAT IT. IS
NOT SUBJECT TO ANY FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS AS YOUR SP NINETY FIVE
WAS LAST YEAR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU LET'S REVIEW
TURNED OUT OF THE PHONE LINES
AND AGAIN WILL STOP AT TWELVE
TEN GO AHEAD MODERATOR. THE
OLDER LINE SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN.
AND HERE MEMBERS HAVE REALLY YOU
WHAT YOU NEED AT THE LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY THANK YOU FOR
THE BUDGET HEARING TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE OUR ONGOING
COMMENTS FROM SENATOR
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED FOR PAID
SICK LEAVE. EARLY ACTION ON IT I
DIDN'T MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS
SPECIALLY HOME CARE PROVIDERS
ONLY ONLY HAVE THREE DAYS TO
CREATE THE CLEANING CARE TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE PROTECTED DURING THE
ONGOING ENDEMIC THANK THE
LEGISLATORS AND ADMINISTRATION
WORKING ON IT IT CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE PROGRESS.
ADDITIONALLY THE HIGHLIGHT
MANNER THIRD COMMENT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE NEED TO IMPROVE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE I'LL GET THAT THAT I'M
PARTICULARLY FOR I TOOK THAT
THAT THEY'RE BETTER PLANS TO
DRAFT A VACCINATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES DURING AND AFTER
HELLO HOME CARE PROVIDERS WITH
THE FINANCIAL BUT THEN INCREASED
COMPENSATION FOR THEIR SERVICES
I GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
TYPICAL COFFERS HERE. FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE V. P. WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF INCLUSION
JAYANTI WORKING THE BUDGET LIKE
WITH THE INVESTMENT FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION TO BE ADOPTED AT
TEN O'CLOCK FOR THE BACK WITHIN. OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE FORTY FOR ONE. THANK
YOU CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION RECOGNITION FOR THE
NEED FOR PAID SICK LEAVE TODAY-
WE JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AN
UNDERSCORE THAT CAN BE BEHIND
THE PROPOSAL AND EVERYTHING THE
THIRD PERSON PUSH OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM CHILDCARE AND CALLED THE
BRAIN- WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
AND CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH YOU ALL. TO GET A SOLUTION
DO NOT POSSIBLE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE HIM A WEEK AFTER THE
WORKERS ON THE FRONTLINE AS WELL
AS THOSE THAT ARE SHOWING UP
EVERY DAY WE ALSO ACCRETION OF
THE DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR TAKING
HOME WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT
RETENTION HOWEVER OUR STAFF
INTEGRATOR AND WE ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME BRINGING IN SAP WE
NEED A BATH EACH OF THOSE
DOLLARS. INCREASE OUR SO CALLED
TIME- PUT THOSE DOLLARS TOWARD
INCREASING THE WEIGHT BENEFIT.
MORE THAN LIKELY WHAT POINT
COMING IN HE- OF THE MONTH TRACK
AND WAIT RATE HE INCREASED WORK
WORTH. AND ABOUT WITH THE BANK
TO LEAVE. INTERNATIONAL THAT
HAPPENED NOT AREA. SIMILARLY I.
JUST I WANT COME WITH THE CREAMY
- THE BUDGET RECOMMENDS DOWN
EASILY AND- BUT CHILD WORKFORCE
THAT OFTEN. AND PUTTING DOLLARS
. A COUPLE THAT ARE COME OUT ON
AVERAGE. TOP IT WOULD BE A
FINANCIAL IN HELPING UP WORKERS
AND BRINGING WANT TO WORK FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAX
WHITTAKER FROM SAID SEVEN ALL.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRENDAN
TAYLOR COME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
REPLACEMENTS AND UPGRADES-
PROGRAM AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THAT AMOUNT. WE KNOW
THAT INCENTIVES FOR THE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM HAD BEEN
REDUCED FROM TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION WHICH IS A MORE THAN ONE
THIRD CAT ADDITIONALLY
IMPLEMENTATION IS FUNDED AT THE
SAME LEVEL DESPITE ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITIES BEING ADDED. I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT YOUR DISTRICT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FUNDING IS AN
AREA WE URGE INVESTMENT SO WE
CAN BETTER RESPOND TO WILDFIRES
ANTS AND OTHER EMERGENCIES AND
ALSO THE BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE WHIP SMART GRID
ACTION PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS LAST
YEAR TO PROVIDE FUNDING AND WE
HOPE YOU DO YOU WILL DO SO
AGAIN. AND LASTLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO RE AUTHORIZE THE ABA
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND COST
EFFECTIVE COM WHEREIN EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE LOCAL
INCENTIVES PROGRAMS THIS YEAR TO
AVOID DISRUPTION AND HELP US
MEET OUR CLEAN AIR ACT.
OBLIGATIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. OUR NEXT COMMENT WAS FROM LINE. SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SANDRA BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION EARLY
ACTION ON A POLITICALLY
EXTENSION EXTENDING COVERAGE
NINETEEN TRICKLING INTO THE
CENTRAL TO KEEPING COLD OPEN
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE LEAVE
FROM PARENTS HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN LOCK WITH INCOME WHEN
COMPARED TO THEIR JOB. AND
SENDING THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL
THANK WE KNOW THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND WE'RE COMMITTED
TO KEEPING SCHOOLS OPEN WE CAN'T
PREVENT OUTBREAKS LIKE SURE AND-
I HOPE TO COPE WITH STRICTLY. I
DON'T TO PLAY OUT THAT WE DON'T
FIVE RIGHT AND COPE WITH. IN A
DAY TO THE FAMILY. I'M CLEAR
UNDERSTOOD THE BUILDING HANDS
BUT IF YOU REFUSE TO CREDIT BACK
REGULAR SICK LEAVE. HOPE IT.
PLEASE WE'RE LEFT WITH NOTHING
TO USE FOR OTHER ILLNESSES. WELL
WE'RE ASKING THAT ANY
RETROACTIVE LANGUAGE AND AN
EXTENSION SHOULD SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE ANY REGULAR SICK LEAVE
ELECTRICAL BUT BE. CREDITED BACK
LADY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT COMES ON LINE
SIXTY NINE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND SHARE- THIS IS JULIE
NOW AN ACTIVE FAULT I HAVE A
THREE POINT B. HAPPENED
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION ONE OKAY OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSED THREE BILLION
FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FUND OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION WE LIKE TO ASK THE
COURT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A SUFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION LIGHT. DUTY
MEDIUM DUTY OUR MISSION. TRUCK
BOX AND DRAINAGE TRY. YOU NAME
IT THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING THE STATE NEEDED- QUITE
COLD. IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE WE WOULD LIKE TO.
RECORD A FINDING. THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN FOR
POLICY INCLUDING FUNDING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN GET- MUCH OF
THE MATERIAL OUT OF THE FOREST
SHE BENEFICIAL YOU. NEED LIKE
FIRE MAP THAT MONEY AND THEN THE
POST IN THE BUDGET A
DIFFERENTIAL TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
MANAGE- TRANSIT. ACCESS AND YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO PUTTING MORE
THAT IN DETAIL AND RIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT. NINE EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY
ONE. EXACTLY WOULD PROTECT US
FROM THE HELP OF MY CURRENT
COMPANY I ADVOCATE I THANK YOU
FOR THE HISTORIC IMPACT LAST
YEAR TOWARD THE COPY OF THE ART
CULTURE CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AND
WORKFORCE I THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR PRACTICALLY OVER EIGHTY
MILLION IN THE THIRD BUT ARCTIC.
COOKING TECHNIQUES IN OUR
COMMUNICATION ONE EQUITIES
LIVING LEGEND AND WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHER THAN
THAT I ALREADY COULD HAVE
COMPLICATIONS BUT HOW QUICKLY
THE BOARD ACT BETWEEN TWENTY ONE
INCREASED FOCUS ON THAT THEY
ARE. TROUBLED ONE DOLLAR QUICKLY
CAPITA. HOPE WE INVITE YOU TO
COME THE BIGGEST IN THE CAR THE
TECHNICIAN WILL BE CONSIDERED A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT IN
INDUSTRIES SUCH AS. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY ONE BY ONE. KATIE
WATER SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AN
EXTENSION OF TWO WEEKS AGO BUT
NINETEENTH UP ON THAT OKAY SICK
LEAVE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA WORKERS
PAID SICK LEAVE SAVE LIVES AND
WE NEED ACTION NOW. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FORTY TWO OR TWO. A GOOD
AFTERNOON ROBERT- TREATING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
TWO POINT THREE PM LOOK I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNORSHIP POLLS OVER GOING
THREE BILLION TOWARDS THE U. I.
UNDER TWO YEARS- PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT- SOME OF
THAT THAT COMES FROM RIGHT EDT
FRAUD EMPLOYERS HAD NO PART IN
BECAUSE THAT. IS MORE COMMON
HUMAN INTEREST TIME ONLY THAT
POINT- SECONDLY I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS A COUPLE OF- SPECIFIC
PROVISION COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED POLITICALLY FILL IN
THAT TOPIC. THEY SHOULD CONSIDER
BUYING CONTACT THE FINANCIAL AID
TO BUSINESSES FOR THE NEW
MANDATE PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
ON POINTS WHICH WERE IN. EFFECT
IN THE PAST ARE NO LONGER IN
EFFECT. SECOND WE BELIEVE THE
CAR OUT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH FEWER THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
SHOULD BE MAINTAINED THAT IT WAS
NINETY FIVE LAST YEAR AND THOSE
THAT ARE APPARENTLY STRUGGLING.
TO KEEP UP PARTICULAR PANDEMIC.
THIRD WE BELIEVE IT SHOULDN'T.
SOME TO ALLOW TO LIMIT ABUSE OF
SICK LEAVE. BY ALLOWING. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REALLY ARE GIVING
IT TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE THANK YOU. AN EXCELLENT ONLINE SEVENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOUR. GOOD MORNING
KATIE HARTMAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I'LL BE
BRIEF EPA OR GET THE LEGISLATURE
TO REINSTATE COVERAGE FOR MENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE AS PART OF EARLY
ACTION THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL IN
KEEPING OUR COLD OPEN ANYTHING.
THANK. NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX. GOOD
MORNING GRIDLOCK OR SEE A
SEVENTY GRADE SCIENCE AND MATH
TEACHER REMODELING SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
HI TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT
RECEPTION THE COPA NINETY. SIXTY
YEARS ALL MY COLLEAGUES
MEDICATION THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINES. SIXTY SIX ZERO.
BUTCHER MEMBERS MY NAME IS COLE
CLEARLY MERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE I THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE FOR RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TOOL AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
STRESS THE URGENCY OF THIS
MOMENT. AND THANK. WE HAVE
BLINDS. SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU JACQUELINE ONE
HERNANDEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- FOR THAT HEARING AND
ALL THE GREAT QUESTION HE'S AKC
RECOGNIZES THAT THIS PROCESS IS
JUST STARTING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COLLABORATIVE
WORK AND THAT LIKE THE HEAD TO
JUST A FEW QUICK POINTS- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSING THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONGOING FUNDING. FOR STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT
IN LOCAL TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE
ESPECIALLY THE HIGHWAY SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM INTERNAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BRANSON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION ROUTES. AND YOU
KNOW IF YOU THOUGHT LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
TYPES OF COMMUNITIES- URBAN AND
RURAL WILL BENEFIT FROM THOSE
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED ON GOING INVESTMENT IN
REDUCING THE I. F. WE WENT- BUT
WHILE WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE INVESTING IN ALTERNATIVE IF
THE HOSPITAL AND COUNTY THE POSE
A GROWTH CAP ON I IF HE REFERRAL
AND THE COUNTY COST SHARING
METHODOLOGY. IF THAT CAPITEC
STATED- EAGER TO ENGAGE IN PERTH
DISCUSSION- WHAT ARE. IN
STAKEHOLDERS AND FISH ON THIS
ISSUE AN ADDITIONAL POINT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO MAINTAIN DISHES
ACCORDING. TO DISCONTINUE THE
ADMISSION OF NEW LPS PATIENTS-
AND- ESTABLISH LPS REDUCTION
TARGETS FOR COUNTY. INSURANCE
COUNTY THAT DON'T RECEIVE DON'T
ACHIEVE THOSE REDUCTION- AND WE-
WE'RE NOT WE'RE OPPOSED TO THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC COMMENT-
HI- SORRY THERE WE HAD TO
LIMITED BUT WE DID HAVE THOSE I.
T. PROBLEMS EARLIER AND I THINK
WE'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF FOOD AND THIS WILL NOW
CONCLUDE OUR FIRST BUDGET
OVERSIGHT. OUR FIRST. SENATE
BUDGET OMMITTEE OVERSIGHT
HEARING AND WITH THAT I WILL
DOUBLE DOWN AND WE'LL ADJOURN
THANK YOU.